So, ich hab Rekord gedrückt. War das in deinem Sinne?
Das war mein Sinne. Hallo, haben wir einen Jingle? Wir haben keinen Jingle noch.
Nee, wir haben heute wieder keinen Jingle. Ich glaube, die Mehrheit war der Meinung, dass kein Jingle besser ist. Dann fängt das auch immer so schön, wie soll ich sagen, launisch an.
Launisch.
Wir sind mit ohne Jingle.
Ja, wir sind ohne Jingle.
Wollen wir uns ein bisschen entschuldigen für das letzte Mal, dass das doch ein bisschen in die Länge ging?
Ja, in die Länge war nicht das Problem. Aber ich denke, wir sind ganz reuig. Das gibt mir wie einfach.
Ich bin ganz reuig. Auf jeden Fall.
Ich auch ein bisschen.
Wir haben uns heute lieb, oder, Max?
Ja, aber Firefox hab ich noch lieber.
You like your Firefox better than me, don't you, Max? Na willkommen auf jeden Fall.
2001 war das.
Ja, war es.
Ich hab aufgepasst.
Ja, hast du aufgepasst. Christenblümchen, Denis. Ja, dann stellen wir uns doch mal vor. Hallo, Denis. Ich bin Denis. Hallo, Max.
Hallo.
Zu meiner Rechten.
Hallo, Tim.
Und hallo, Tim. Zu meiner, in mir selbst drin.
Das sieht voll nachvolley aus.
Ist eine Tim-zentrierte Schilderung, ne? Ist es jetzt so?
Ja, das ist ja.
So bin ich.
Du bist jetzt quasi... Ich? Das schwarze Loch, genau.
Ich bin das Zentrum. Und das Zentrum hat auch die Liste mit den tollen Themen, die wir heute gesagt haben. Jetzt haben wir extra den Aufnahmetermin ein bisschen nach hinten geschoben, denn wir schreiben heute den 11. Juli und es ist einer dieser Termine, wo die ganze Macintosh-Landschaft völlig verstört ist und völlig zittrig diesen Moment erwartet hat, dass nun endlich, endlich das tolle iPhone, das neue iPhone 3G kommt. Und dann kam's...
Ich dachte, die neue Wacom-Version.
Allerdings sieht es jetzt, Stand 1836, alles noch recht ruckelig aus. Also verkauft worden ist es wohl tatsächlich weltweit. Nicht überall haben die Leute was bekommen.
Gestern gab es schon die ersten Richter aus Neuseeland, wo es schon Leute hatten, habe ich gehört.
Genau.
Ich hatte heute erst zwei in der Hand.
Neue?
Ach, du hattest schon eins in der Hand.
Zwei Leute, die nur auf einmal.
Wer denn? Mein geschätzter Kollege Johnny Häusler hat eins aufgetrieben.
Aber der hat doch noch ausführlich geblockt, dass er keins bekommen durfte.
Der hat ausführlich geblockt, dass er keins bekommen durfte. Und dann hat Sascha, Sascha Lobo, am Kudamm einen Laden aufgetrieben, wo er dann doch eins gekriegt hat, die ihm dann eins zurückgelegt haben. Und dann hat es zuerst sich Sascha eins geholt, dann ist Johnny das erste Mal seit wahrscheinlich gefühlten 48 Jahren mit der U-Bahn gefahren. Ach. Ganz schnell dahin, weil der ist kein U-Bahn-Freund. Und hat sich auch ein iPhone geholt und Sascha hat ein weißes und Johnny hat ein schwarzes und darum hatte ich schon die Gelegenheit auf dem neuen iPhone rum zu gehen.
Echt? Sascha hat ein Damen-iPhone?
Sascha hat ein Damen-iPhone.
Und was machen die mit ihren Alten?
Das ist die große Frage, was man damit macht. Wahrscheinlich warten bis das Dev-Team in die Potte kommt und dann entweder Freunde verschenken oder Verwandte oder verkloppen. Du hast doch schon eins.
Du meinst, bis das iPhone-Dev-Team auch die 2.0-Version gehackt hat. Angeblich ist das schon so.
Bei Gizmodo stand schon, aber ich finde auf der Webseite nichts so lange.
Na die Betas haben die auch schon die ganze Zeit gehackt, aber dann haben sie nach der Beta 4 irgendwie aufgehört. Das heißt ihr Pornage Tool 1.1 unterstützt halt bis zur Beta 4 und danach nichts. Und seitdem ist noch nichts mehr gekommen.
Aber bei Gizmodo war gestern die beha- Also die haben den App Store getestet. Der lief gestern schon und die haben eine Version auf jeden Fall schon am Laufen gehabt, die zwei Builds vor der aktuellen, vor der ausgelieferten Version ist. Also insofern ist die Hoffnung groß, dass sie das-
Ich denke, dass sie von Apple auch nichts geändert haben. Die sind wahrscheinlich auch noch am Durchtesten, dass alles sicher ist und dass irgendwie nichts kaputt geht. Weil ich hab da auch Gerüchte gehört, dass dieses Cibri Hack, also dieses Z-iPhone-Hacker-Tool von diesem Cibri, dass das irgendwelche Baseband-Kalibrierung oder Berierungstabellen zerstören würde oder könnte. Und vielleicht sind die deswegen ein bisschen vorsichtiger.
Du meinst, weil sie ähnlich vorgehen?
Na, weil sie das eher ganz auf die Sauber machen wollen und nicht da so böse rumhacken. Zum Beispiel dieses Z-iPhone, auch in irgendeiner Zwischenversion, dafür gesorgt, dass alle iPhones die gleiche Mac-Adresse hatten.
Nein.
Doch, doch, das hat's gemacht.
Auf dem WLAN?
Also von diesen Z-iPhone-Sybrietypen sollte man echt die Finger lassen.
Aber vielleicht liegt es auch daran, dass es gar nicht so sichern wollen, sondern dass sie Blogartikel darüber schreiben, wie sie alle losrennen und neue iPhones kaufen wollen und wahrscheinlich gucken wollen, ob ihre Software auf einen neuen iPhone ist.
Also die alten iPhones sind auf jeden Fall jetzt hier wahrscheinlich sehr gefragt, solange es so schwierig ist, ein neues iPhone überhaupt zu bekommen, ohne sich gleich einen Vertrag an die Backe zu kleben. Ich finde es ja erstaunlich, dass die Leute jetzt wirklich auf die...
Interessiert euch denn mein erster Eindruck überhaupt? Also es ist ein Hauch dicker, aber wirklich nur ein Hauch. Wenn man es so auf den Tisch legt, dann sieht man es ein bisschen dicker, ich glaube im Alltag überhaupt nicht.
Ist das nicht so rund innen und wackelt das nicht, wenn es auf dem Tisch liegt?
Es liegt relativ stabil, also man könnte es wahrscheinlich runterdrücken, aber der Schwerpunkt ist schon so, dass es vernünftig daliegt. Es ist ein bisschen griffiger als das alte. Also beim alten ist es ja doch ein bisschen gerutscht, aber noch lange nicht griffig genug, also schon relativ glatt. Was unglaublich viel besser ist, ist der Lautsprecher. Der ist viel, viel lauter, viel, viel klarer, wirklich um einiges besser.
Haben sie auch großartig erzählt, ne?
Telefonqualität weiß ich noch nicht. GPS war überraschend schnell, als ich es ausprobiert habe. Also im Wohnraum funktioniert es natürlich nicht, genauso wie jedes GPS-Gerät, aber ich bin kurz rausgegangen.
Was heißt überraschend schnell?
Also es fängt erstmal an, dass es mir angezeigt hat, als ich in Berlin bin, das war so nach 10 Sekunden der Fall, würde ich sagen.
Das wusste er aber dann wahrscheinlich aus der Cell-Info und nicht unbedingt aus der GPS-Info. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es ja so, dass das iPhone alle drei verfügbaren Navigationsmittel zusammennimmt und immer aus der Erkauung.
Genau, aber diese allererste Information war definitiv schneller da, als ich bisher immer die Information hatte, wo ich bin. Also bei dem ist es so, auf Basis von WLAN, da sucht er, sucht er, sucht er, sucht er, sucht er und dann zeigt er mir irgendwann plötzlich Punkt an.
Weil bei der 114er Version macht er ja erst beide Requests und rechnet dann aus, wo er ist und mit der neuen Version macht er erst diesen Sale-Request und zoomt dann schon mal rein und dann kommen erst andere Requests.
Genau, das hat man deutlich gesehen, wie er dann so, also zuerst hat er Berlin angezeigt, dann ging er weiter runter, Kreuzberg schon nah dran, also dass man auf jeden Fall schon die Straße erkennen konnte und eigentlich schon gute Informationen hatte, wo man ist so um 100 Meter versetzt, würde ich mal schätzen, oder um 30, 40 Meter und dann in der dritten Stufe und das hat vielleicht so 40, 50 Sekunden gedauert, dann spot on.
Also so richtig mit Hollywood-Dramatik.
Das war schon, das war, das war schon mit Hollywood-Dramatik.
Auf welchem Planeten sind wir? Erde. Und dann immer weiter reingezoomt.
Also schneller als ein N95 zum Beispiel, wobei ein N95 hatte ich noch nie einen Fix hinbekommen, aber auch schneller als die meisten GPS-Geräte, die ich kenne.
Ich hab neulich so eine Horde von Nokia, naja, was darf ich jetzt sagen? Also Leuten, die viel mit Nokia-Telefonen zu tun haben, die meinten ja, dass das N95 sich ja eigentlich ganz wunderbar verkaufen würde. Viele Millionen Mal meinten sie. Das konnte ich nicht so richtig überprüfen, hab ich jetzt erst mal so geschluckt. Ich war aber ganz froh, dass irgendwie ein N95 angeblich in 30 Sekunden seinen Fix kriegt. Ich fand das ja eigentlich nicht so schnell.
Vielleicht haben sie in der Software irgendwas verbessert.
Also das, was ich damals hatte, ganz am Anfang haben wir jetzt auch AGPS.
Also die Firmware hab ich nie, mit AGPS hab ich nie gehabt. Ich hab eine relativ frühe Firmware gehabt. Wie gesagt, ich hab nie ein Fixing gekriegt. Ich hab getan, was ich konnte. Ich hab mir wirklich Mühe gegeben, eine Verbindung herzustellen. Das war nicht drin.
Sie haben per Firmware-Update AGPS nachgerüstet.
Genau.
Das was das iPhone jetzt auch hat. Haben wir ja schon drüber geredet.
Und was ich ein bisschen merkwürdig fand, waren die 3G-Qualitäten, also die UMTS-Qualitäten, weil entweder haben wir bei uns im Büro kein UMTS bei T-Mobile, was ich mir mitten in Kreuzberg eigentlich nicht so...
Du siehst es ja an dem Symbol, da steht der 3G dann drin.
Genau, oder der Empfang ist auch schlecht, weil es kam zwischendurch immer mal das Symbol und ist dann sofort, sobald du gesurft bist, ist es eigentlich wieder verschwunden. Und...
Ja, ich schalte hier auch mal die Klingel aus.
Das war so ein bisschen so, na hoffentlich wird das beim nächsten... Also hoffentlich ist das nur bei uns im Büro so. Und die Empfangsqualität ist nicht im Allgemeinen so schlecht. Also das war nicht so der Hammer. Ansonsten eigentlich bin ich... Eigentlich bin ich erschreckend ruhig geblieben. Für meine Verhältnisse muss ich sagen.
Du bist nicht wie es sich für einen Apple-Fanboy gehört.
Na, er hat ja auch schon eins.
Also ich werde mir ziemlich sicher eins holen. Ich glaube in Belgien wahrscheinlich dann, so ein scheiß Teures.
Ich bin auch auf der belgischen Spur.
Du bist auch auf der belgischen Spur. Ich habe zwei Kontakte schon nach Belgien, die sich bereit erklärt haben mir eins...
Ich habe bisher nur einen angeschrieben, von dem ich noch nicht weiß, ob er sich bereit erklärt hat.
Vielleicht hast du ja noch mehr Anlaufpunkte.
Ich kenne jemanden in Aachen, das ist so um die Ecke.
Brauchen wir nur rüberfahren. Wir sollten kurz erklären für die Leute, die nicht wissen, wovon wir reden. Belgien scheint offensichtlich die besten Gesetze in Europa zu haben und verbietet ein SimLog oder NetLog. Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Es verbietet das Bandeln, das Zwangsbandeln von irgendwas.
Das haben die Franzosen auch.
Bei den Franzosen ist es so, dass du es machen kannst, aber du musst zusätzlich noch einen Unlocked noch separat anbieten. Nicht, dass ich mich jetzt mit der Materie in ich vertraut hätte, aber das ist das, was ich aus dem Pressrelease herausgelesen habe und vor allem aus der Reuters-Meldung dazu, dass das sozusagen so zu sein hat. Mobistar hat sich also entschlossen, das Telefon quasi subventionsfrei anzubieten. Und ich schätze mal, hier sehen wir auch den wahren Preis des iPhones. Plus vielleicht noch ein bisschen extra, weil sie auch natürlich damit rechnen müssen, dass nun ganz Europa nach Belgien pilgert, um ihnen die Läden leer zu kaufen. Aber 500, jetzt muss ich da nochmal gucken, 615 für das große inklusive Märchensteuer. Also für das große Telefon. Und 125 für das kleine.
Anstatt Butterfahrten gibt es dann ein iPhone-Fahrt nach Belgien?
Naja, kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Definitiv.
Aber ich meine, es ist ein iPhone 3G, es hat GPS, es ist ein vollwertiger iPod und es hat keinerlei Netlocks und es hat auch keinerlei Vertragsbindungen. Das heißt, man kann es einfach in jedem Land, wo man es betreiben will, mit einem Tarif, der einem angemessen erscheint, betreiben und da kann man echt eine Menge Geld sparen. Also ich habe meinen Tarif durchgerechnet, was ich zahlen würde jetzt mit diesen Telekom-Tarifen von der Telekom und ich muss sagen, es geht nicht. Das ist einfach, also ich habe sehr 90 Euro gewonnen.
Also der Tarif wäre für mich glaube ich okay, aber das kostet halt 90 Euro im Monat.
Das kostet halt 90 Euro im Monat. Das ist schon echt eine Menge Holz. Und vor allem mit dieser blöden Kostenfalle, wenn man im Ausland ist. Und ich bin einfach häufig im europäischen Ausland. Und Datentarife im Ausland und Telefon-Tarife im Ausland, erstmal sind die nicht wohl dokumentiert, was man überhaupt bezahlt. Aber bei den Datentarifen weiß man es ja, da werden einfach sinnlose Beträge genommen.
Also in Spanien waren es, um jetzt mal ein bisschen auf O2 reinzuholen, wir werden ja mal, wir wurden ja neulich kritisiert, irgendwie in den Kommentaren, das wäre O2 zu sehr lohnen, um auf O2 einzukloppen, 16 Cent pro 10 Kilobyte. Das war sagenhaft.
16 Cent auf was?
10 Kilobyte, pro angefangene 10 Kilobyte.
Ah ja, das ist so was ähnliches, was ich in Österreich bezahlt habe. 170 Euro hab ich für 10 Websites bezahlt. Hab ich da schon mal drüber gestunken? Das ist wirklich furchtbar. Ich mein, das Schlimme ist, dass die auch wenig dagegen tun können, derzeit, weil sie sich ja alle gegenseitig blockieren. Sie haben einfach diese Hoden-Roming, Data-Roming-Tarife, die sie sich gegenseitig berechnen und deswegen können die gar nicht beliebig andere Tarife machen. Wahrscheinlich muss hier jemand mal von der EU kommen.
Dann macht er ja andauernd zu jedem Sommer irgendwie dieses SMS-Gebühren europaweit senken und die Roaming-Gebühren auch, nur fruchtet das ja nicht immer so richtig.
Kein Zweifel, also ich hab auch gehört, dass da sich was tut.
Also gerade bei den Telefon-Tarifen, das ist immer noch zu teuer, klar, aber das ist dramatisch billiger als vor ein paar Jahren.
Genau, aber im Data-Bereich wird halt immer noch richtig abgeräumt.
Das geht halt gar nicht.
Die Kostenfalle ist halt extrem. Ist echt extrem. Es gab ja auch diesen Fall, da gab es eine Meldung auf Zeltarif. Es war ein etwas komplizierter Fall, da hat sich irgendwie ein Mittel, ein iPhone aus den USA erworben und hat da irgendwie schon einen T-Mobile-Vertrag, irgendwie diesen Basics-Tarif. Das war ja dann ein bisschen zu teuer damit, weil da irgendwie 700 Euro GPS-Kosten aufkam. Und dann hat ihnen die Kunden-Hotline von T-Mobile aber empfohlen, ach, dann wechseln sie doch in unseren iPhone-Tarif, in den Complete-M-Tarif. Und dann haben sie irgendwie diesen Tarif offiziell geschaltet und dann war sie ganz glücklich und hat einfach weiter telefoniert und dann hat sie irgendwie eine 4000-Euro-Rechnung bekommen. Ja, weil dieser Tarif nämlich erst dann funktioniert, wenn du dein Telefon auch dann nochmal mit iTunes wirklich aktivierst. Und das haben sie ihr natürlich nicht gesagt. Und da merkt man mal, wie verworren und verflochten und verstörend komplex das alles immer noch ist.
Ja, warum Telefon-Tarife so unglaublich scheiße sein müssen, das möchte ich mir auch meinen.
Genau. Und deswegen habe ich einfach kein Interesse an so einem Telefon, was irgendwie so eine Voodoo-Verbindung hat mit irgendeinem Tarif, mit irgendeinem Provider. Ich will das einfach nicht. Da zahle ich lieber am Anfang meine Strafgebühr und bin dann frei. Und muss mir irgendwie keine Gedanken darüber machen. Zumindest nicht mehr, als man sich sowieso über Telekom-Tarife Gedanken machen muss. Aber gibt es denn auch irgendwas zu dem iPhone 3G zu sagen? Es hat GPS, es hat einen besseren Lautsprecher.
Das haben wir nun alle schon tausendmal gehört. Man braucht jetzt keinen Kopfhöreradapter mehr, um normale Kopfhörer reinzukriegen.
Das ist auch ein echtes Feature.
Und?
Also für mich ist das ein echtes Feature. Ja klar. Also meine Kopfhörer, die ich gerne betreiben würde, die hängen hier irgendwie und die würden da auch nicht reinpassen.
Jedenfalls nicht ohne Adapter.
So ein dickes Teil, hätte nie und nimmer da reingepasst. Ich zeig das hier gerade mal so rum. Und...
Ist jetzt der normale Walkman, iPod, Standard, Klinkenstecker, den die Kopfhörer so haben.
Genau, jetzt ist das bündig mit dem Gehäuse und jetzt dürfte da alles reinpassen.
Eigentlich ist das neue iPhone, würde ich sagen, wirklich ziemlich exakt das, was das erste iPhone im Idealfall gewesen wäre.
Das ist ja bei allen Sachen, also oft so. Erste Kinderkrankheiten, wo es erst mal gefixt wird. Aber da habe ich noch von einem Feature gehört. Ich weiß noch nicht, wie es geht, aber dieses Apple Remote. Du hast da dich wohl umgeguckt, erzähl doch mal.
Naja, der App Store hat ja nun eröffnet.
Jetzt kommen wir vom... Da wir ja zu viel über das iPhone reden, hätte ich jetzt den folgenden Vorschlag zu meinen, wir gehen jetzt vom iPhone weg und unterhalten uns über US-10 auf dem iPhone, womit wir wieder eindeutig bei einem Neckthema werden. Und dazu gehört der App Store, ja?
Ach naja, ich glaube...
Bei einem Programm ist eigentlich nichts dazu gekommen, richtig?
Ich kann diese Frage nicht verstehen. Bei welchem Programm?
Beim iPhone. So ein Auslieferzustand ist eigentlich, außer das Kontext, jetzt auch eine eigene Applikation. Ist nicht mehr so wie vorher.
Na ja, es kommen insofern jetzt viele Programme dazu, als dass in dem App Store halt so an die 150 kostenlose Programme zum runterladen sind.
Und es sind einige Programme doch wesentlich verbessert. Also es ist...
Wie viele Programme hast du gesagt?
150?
550. Ich hab die Wette sozusagen schon gewonnen.
Freie.
Ach so. Aber insgesamt 550. Wir hatten ja gewettet, ne?
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, was ich gewettet hab. Was hab ich denn gewettet?
Bei dir weiß ich nicht. Ich hab gesagt 500 und du hast sowas von 100 gesagt.
Ich hab gesagt deutlich weniger gesagt. Jaja, ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, was ich gesagt hab. Oh Gott, ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich gesagt hab. 1000? Ich hab bestimmt 1000 gesagt, oder?
Du kannst ja der Sendung nochmal anhören.
Wobei ich hab mir dadurch...
Bis wann? Bis Ende Juni?
Juli.
Bis Ende Juli 1000?
Weiß nicht, ob du es gesagt hast. Ich hab gesagt 500.
Also wenn ich das gesagt habe, würde ich immer noch meinen, dass das hinhaut. Weil jetzt kommen die auch bamm, bamm, bamm, kommt jetzt alles nach dem anderen.
Ich hoffe auch bessere Tools als irgendwie Tipp-Berechner. Also Trinkgeld-Berechner-Programme siebenmal oder was. Also ist auch echt eine Menge Müll dabei. Aber ist klar, jeder will natürlich jetzt irgendwie...
Da ist jetzt viel obvious Zeug dabei. Trotzdem dürfte 550 Applikationen schon mal alles übersteigen, was auf einer anderen Mobilplattform sinnvoll direkt im Zug ist.
Ich hab mir vorhin einiges angeguckt, da ist sehr, sehr viel Schrott dabei. Also da sind ein paar ganz nette Programme dabei. Also was ich immer hervorheben möchte, das war ein NetNews-Wire auf dem iPhone, was mir sehr, sehr gut gefallen hat. Der erste Sync dauert relativ lange, aber danach ist es ein wirklich schickes Programm, was ich mir auf jeden Fall installieren werde.
Hast du auch schon ausprobiert?
Das hab ich vorhin ausprobiert. Die diversen Twitter-Klien, also gerade Twitterific, war eher enttäuschend, weil langsame Scrollgeschwindigkeit.
Aber das hat auch so einen Usability-Preis abgeräumt.
Also, was ich gesehen habe, fand ich es eher naja. Und, also wirklich relativ langsam. Man musste sehr viel rumtippen, um irgendwo hinzukommen, also um jemanden eine Direktnachricht zu schicken. Das war relativ anstrengend. Dann gibt es so komplette Gagga-Applikationen, wie zum Beispiel so eine Warnlampe. Ich glaube, das gab es schon. Das gab es schon für das gehackte iPhone. Wenn man überfallen wird, dann soll man doch rasch sein iPhone aus der Tasche holen, soll dieses Programm starten. Einmal aufs Display ditchen und dann macht es so. Und vorher die Lautstärke hochstellen.
Das ist das Telefon.
Und das ist die gesamte Applikation.
Es gibt auch Taschenlampen-Applikationen, die machen das Display komplett weiß und komplett hell. Da gibt es drei Stück davon.
Das gibt es im App Store. Das gab es vorher auch schon. Das wäre eine coole Anwendung. Für Porn gab es früher eine Spiegel-Applikation, die das Display extrem dunkel gemacht hat, sodass man sich im Display erkennen konnte. Das ist jetzt quasi die Ausfunktion beim iPhone, wenn das iPhone einfach aus ist.
Aber es sind erstaunlich viele Spiele auch dabei. Hast du ein paar Spiele ausprobiert?
Spiele habe ich nicht ausprobiert, weil es nicht mein iPhone war und weil die meisten Spiele doch Geld kosten. Und ich nicht auf fremde iTunes-Kosten kaufen wollte.
Johnny war geizig sozusagen und wollte kein Spiel.
Ich habe noch nichts gekauft, was man kaufen musste. Ich glaube nicht, dass er es ausprobieren wird. Aber das soll er selber machen. Wenn ich da schon rumspielen kann mit dem Ding, dann...
Was soll man auch kaufen? Es gibt ja keinen Porno auf dem iPhone.
Es gibt ja keinen Porno auf dem iPhone. Ja, aber ein paar Programme, die ich vermissen will, gibt es nicht. Köln gibt es per Definition nicht. Mein Ad-Blocker z.B., der Werbung rausfiltert, was gerade über GPS relativ sinnvoll ist. Audio Scrubbler, der mitaufzeichnet, was ich so höre und das dann überträgt über die Luft. Und mein Last FM-Profil aktualisiert und schärft.
Mitgelauscht, was du so hörst, also was du für Musik hörst.
Also ja, genau, was ich für Musik höre. Ich dachte, jetzt passt. Hab ich noch was. Und es gibt so eine schöne, das nutze ich allerdings nicht, so ein Programm, das einem direkt auf dem Home-Display anzeigt, was für Termine anstehen und sowas. Sowas dürfte auch nicht möglich sein, mit dem App Store Programm.
Der App Store. Ja, App Store präsentiert sich zumindest in iTunes so ähnlich wie halt sonst auch alles. Also man kauft jetzt einfach so, wie man vorher schon die Spiele für ein iPod gekauft hat, kauft man halt jetzt beliebige Applikationen. Ich guck mir hier gerade mal die Top-Ups-Liste an.
Wie war das mit dem iPod? Ich hab da nie ein Spiel für gekauft, wenn man das gelöscht hat und nochmal holen wollt. Kriegt man das dann?
Angeblich kriegt man es jetzt wieder.
Genau, jetzt gesagt er.
Also das hab ich gelesen, dass dem jetzt so sei, das war aber vorher nicht so.
Also es ist so, ich hab's gesehen. Also er hat mir gesagt, hey, das Programm haben sie schon.
Dann können sie das auch bitte gleich mal für die Musik auch machen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Eigentlich schon. Weil ich meine, sie wissen alles, was man gekauft hat und zeigen einem das auch gerne mal an. Aber es ist einfach nochmal... Das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht. Zumal es ja nun eh alles gesichert ist. Also das ist wirklich Quatsch.
Das ist übrigens ganz lustig, die Installation dieser Software. Es erscheint ein kleines Icon. Das Programm Icon erscheint im Dashboard, im Springboard. Und dann hat man so einen kleinen Ladebicon unten drin, der nach und nach voll wird. Wenn es installiert ist, dann ding, erscheint das Icon. Könnte noch ein bisschen hübscher animiert sein, aber ist schon echt ganz niedlich gemacht.
Ja, weil manche Programme ja ziemlich lange zum Laden brauchen und dann kann man sein Telefon hinlegen und der macht dann dann rund, irgendwann ist da Super Monkey Ball.
Man kann auch weitermachen.
Mehrere Megabyte groß.
Ich schau hier gerade auf die Top 100. Das ist vielleicht mal ganz erwähnenswert. Also auf jeden Fall erstaunlich viele Spiele in der Top 10. Also eigentlich besteht die Top 10 ausschließlich aus Spielen.
Ist das die freie? Ist das die meistverkauften Programme oder die meisten Programme überhaupt?
Das sind alles Programme, die was kosten.
Weil direkt auf dem Gerät gibt es eine Unterscheidung zwischen meistgeladene Programme und meistgekaufte Programme.
Und vielleicht gibt es die Liste hier auch. Ich habe hier nur gerade Top Ups. Ah ja, genau, Top Ups kostenlos gibt es auch. Aber vielleicht gehen wir mal kurz auf gekauft, weil das finde ich eigentlich gerade ganz interessant. Also Platz 1, wer hätte es anders gedacht, so bei Monkey Ball, das ist dann wirklich auch gefeatured worden ohne Ende, aber es ist halt auch ein cooles Spiel.
Aber es soll ziemlich schwer sein, habe ich gehört. Geht eigentlich, oder?
Das will man ja auch erwarten, dass ein Spiel schwer ist. Acht Euro ist einfach mal... Nix.
Okay, wir haben es runtergeladen.
Das sehe ich hier leider im iTunes nicht, das sieht man im Upstore, glaube ich, wird dann angezeigt, wie häufig das runtergeladen wird.
Ach, das habe ich noch nicht geguckt.
Schade, das ist natürlich schön. Gestern im Yorck, ich bin ja in so einem Channel immer, da haben die was berichtet, da war eine Stunde lang online der Laden und da haben die knappe 4000 Monkey Balls verkauft.
Also die letzte Zahl, die ich jetzt gesehen habe, war schon eher im fünfstelligen Bereich.
Also ich glaube, wenn man ein schönes Programm schafft, für einen iTunes Store zu schreiben, dann hat man wahrscheinlich ausgesorgt. Also nicht ausgesorgt, aber dann kann man sich...
Da kann man auf jeden Fall ordentlich Geld verdienen. Das ist definitiv so. Und ich glaube, das werden jetzt auch demnächst hier so einige Leute machen. Schauen wir nochmal, was sich noch verkauft. Platz zwei ist Shoppinglist, die Einkaufsliste. 80 Cent.
Also...
Platz drei ist dieses Band, das, glaube ich, in dieser Keynote gefeaturet wurde. Das habe ich aber übersprungen, das hat mich nicht so interessiert.
Das ist ganz lustig, das habe ich auf meinem iPhone drauf. Das gab es früher.
Da kann man halt Musik mit so Jam-Sessions machen.
Das ist echt ein hübsches Programm. Da hat man alle möglichen Musikinstrumente. Das ist echt ziemlich nett. Starkzeug, Piano, dann die üblichen Drum-Machines und sowas. Das ist echt ganz niedlich.
Und Platz vier ist Texas Hold'em.
Kann man auch immer gebrauchen?
Poker!
Pokern?
Na, was online funktioniert, das funktioniert halt auch offline. Achso. Das ist glaube ich nur ein Spiel ohne Internet.
Ich glaube, wenn man...
Das würde aber nicht lange dauern, bis dann auch solche Interfaces kommen für Online-Dienste.
Das wird dann aber wahrscheinlich auch nichts kosten, sondern das lassen sich wahrscheinlich die Hersteller dann sponsern, sind das, und machen das über die Umsetzung weg.
Schach wird noch kommen. Online-Schach. Du bist das unterwegs und dann ah, mein Gegner hat wieder einen neuen Zug gemacht.
Also ich finde ja lustig, auf Platz 29 und auf Platz 33 sind jeweils zwei Taschenlampen für 80 Cent, die nichts weitermachen, als das Display weiß zu schalten.
Tja, schreibe ich auch 70 Cent.
Na, siehst du mal, das ist den Leuten, das ist nämlich immer wieder der Punkt. Gekauft wird, was convenient ist. Wenn es den Leuten, also das Shopping, das überrascht mich überhaupt nicht. Also für mich wäre auch die totale Killer-Applikation wäre so ein Einkaufssupporting-Tool, was aber echt sophisticated ist.
Was aber von Mami von zuhause noch remote schnell Sachen rausschieben können soll, das wäre der Hammer.
Wieso sagt Mami dir, was du einkaufen sollst?
Mir nicht mehr.
Aber?
Früher.
Mami, die kleinen Kinder irgendwie für uns zu steuern, meinst du?
Klar, weil die Liste ist, es gibt keine fertigen Listen.
Mami weiß ja, was gekauft werden.
Oder wie auch immer, dass man remote von seinen Kumpels, für die man einkauft, dass die noch sagen können, bring mal Folgendes auch noch mit.
Dass man Mami noch was auf die Shoppingliste schickt.
Jemand anderem halt, das wär cool.
Ich würde was anderes cool finden. Und zwar mein Hauptproblem beim Einkaufen, also es gibt viele Probleme, aber ein Ding ist, man will Preisvergleiche machen. Und man will sozusagen in mehreren Läden einkaufen. Und ich möchte gerne eine Applikation haben, die nicht nur jetzt meine Liste, was ich einkaufe, hat, sondern die auch eine Produktdatenbank übers Web hat.
Und die dir gleich ausrechnet, wenn du in den Laden gehst, ist es billiger oder wenn du in den Daten gehst, ist es billiger?
Ich möchte jetzt sagen, ich möchte weniger laufen oder ich möchte weniger bezahlen. Und dass es mir dann auch gleich sagt, welcher Laden halt in meiner Nähe ist, da kann man halt mit GPS und so, weißt du, der kürzeste Weg, um das Produkt zu bekommen, was du haben willst und so. Und dass man auch im Laden gleich die Barcodes scannen kann, die Preise dazu eintragen kann, was es hier kostet und so weiter.
Die sollen einfach ihre Preise mal online abrufbar machen.
Häufig hast du ja auch sowas wie Barcodes nicht. Ich meine, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwo Petersilie-Kurs oder Butter und so...
Die intern müssen ja auch irgendwas haben. Die kaufen das ja auch alles ein. Die machen ja auch alles nur mit Computergürteln. Können sie eigentlich auch gerade ihre aktuellen Preise rausrücken.
Was ich noch viel witziger finde eigentlich als die bezahlten Programme, sind ja die kostenlosen Programme. Und da ist die Taschenlampe auf Platz drei. Es gibt eine kostenlose Taschenlampe. Und besonders schön sind da die Screenshots. Einfach zweimal weiße Fläche. Großartig.
Das heißt einfach light und es ist kostenlos. Und die anderen zahlen einfach dafür.
Die Screenshots sind super.
Es gibt glaube ich sogar zwei Screenshots.
Ja, beide sind weiß.
Beide weiß. Das ist ja cool.
Wie gesagt, Net News Fire ist auf jeden Fall, wenn man Net News Fire auf dem Mac hat, schön synchronisieren.
Super Bewertung auch mit der Erklärung hier. Das sind die besten Screenshots, die ich je gesehen habe.
Diese Website, das ist eigentlich schon... Ach, von Erika Sardun ist das. Das ist die Erklärerin von TuAv.
Die ist auch iPhone-mäßig ganz aktiv.
Also, wir stellen fest, es bewegt sich hier eine Menge. Wir haben natürlich jetzt noch eine ganze Menge Apps, die vielleicht, naja, vielleicht ein bisschen sinnlos sind, aber die trotzdem irgendwas tun und da kann auch jemand glücklich werden. Schad ja nix, aber vor allem es ist da und es funktioniert und vor allem es gibt auch richtige Programme. Zum Beispiel hat Omni Group relativ schnell ihr OmniFocus gebracht, ihr Getting Things Done Tool für To-Do-Listen und Tra-La-La-Verwaltung.
Würde ich sofort trafen.
15 Dollar und ist trotzdem auf Platz...
Hab ich gehört, dass das Location basiert ist. Dass man sagen kann, ich bin jetzt gerade da und da bzw. mit der eingebauten Lokalisierung bin ich gerade da und da. Was wollte ich denn da machen?
Dann kann man in die Location so einen Kontext machen. Das heißt, was würde ich zu Hause tun? Was will ich im Laden tun? Was will ich im Büro machen? Das ist auch sehr klug.
Ein virtuelles Bier mit dem Namen E-Bier, E auf Deutsch geschrieben, für 2,39. Für den Preis kauf ich ein echtes Bier.
Ja, aber dann hast du es nicht auf deinem iPhone.
Ach, das kauf ich aber wirklich. Guck dir das mal an, das kippt so richtig weg, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe. Dass das mit dem Beschleunigungs-Sensor, dass man das wirklich so leer trinken kann.
Nein, das ist sozusagen das Bild, das Live-Bild von einem Bier, sodass man dann an seinem iPhone trinken kann. Nein, oh Mann.
Aber ich meine, das könnte doch wirklich so sein, dass es mit Beschleunigungs-Sensor ist.
2,39 und das ist auch noch in der Top 15.
Aber ich meine, der Kneipers ist ja mit einem schönen Gag. Also ich meine, das muss man wirklich sagen.
Ja, siehst du mal, wofür die Leute alles Geld ausgegeben.
Also die 2,39 würde ich eher ausgeben als die 79 Cent für eine blöde Lampe.
Wie auch immer. Also was mir ein ganz heißer Kandidat zu sein scheint für kaufen, ist auch hier von den Coding Monkeys, der Circulator. Das ist einfach mal die Anwendung, die man haben will. Das ist so ein Verleih-Merk-Tool.
Wem man was geliehen hat, das heißt das.
Genau, da kannst du sagen, Person X, Y hat das und das und das mir dann und dann wiedergegeben. Und dann kannst du auch gleich ein Foto von dem Objekt machen und das sozusagen mit ablegen. Und wenn du dann später erinnern willst, kannst du gleich eine SMS verschicken. So eine ganz bedrohliche. Bzw. kannst du dann wählen, wie freundlich die SMS sein. Kannst du ein Template machen für freundlich, neutral oder angry. Kannst du dann sozusagen den richtigen Button drücken, der deiner, wie soll ich sagen, deiner Meinung über den ausleidenden Ausdruck verleiht.
Ich habe gestern ein YouTube-Video gesehen von einem iPhone-Programm. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das schon gibt. Ich glaube noch nicht, denn sonst wäre es kein Video, obwohl es könnte trotzdem sein, dass es das schon gibt. Und zwar ein Last FM Client, wo man halt seine Musik brausen kann, auch irgendwie die Musik von anderen Usern brausen kann, Toplisten sieht. Also es fasst so, sah schon so ein bisschen iTunes-mäßig aus, nur war halt für Last FM auch mit Abspielen und allem Möglichen drum und dran.
Aber da muss ich mal sagen, benutzt du das? Ich hab hier so ein lustiges kleines...
Es war nur ein YouTube-Video.
Ich hab hier so ein lustiges kleines Programm, das heißt Mobile Scrubble. Scrubbler, das hab ich auf meinem 114-Firma vor iPhone drauf, und das macht exakt das.
Mit Last FM?
Mit Last FM.
Ne, ich nicht.
Ich nicht wirklich, ich probier's immer mal wieder, aber so richtig warm werde ich damit leider nicht.
Ist es nicht eigentlich illegal, wenn man darüber Musik abspielen kann? Das kann ich verstehen, nicht so ganz wie... Illegal? Na, die haben ja anscheinend die ganze Musik da.
Du musst ja dann eigentlich einen Account bestellen, wenn du deine eigene Musik... Also das basiert ja darauf, dass du kannst zum Anfüttert werden, kannst du von deinen Freunden Musik hören und so was, aber die aufgrund deines Profils zusammengestellte Musik kannst du nur hören, wenn du dir einen Account bei denen kaufst. Dafür gibst du Geld raus und wie legal oder illegal das dann ist, weiß ich nicht, aber dafür bezahlt was und dafür müsste eigentlich auch was an die entsprechende Musikindustrie gehen.
Dafür gibts demnächst einen kleinen und der war ziemlich schick.
Auch an Independence haben sie jetzt bekannt gegeben. Also Last FM will auch Independence.
Das ist auch ein lustiger Programm. Da kann man sich so lustige Mundbilder übers Gesicht legen und kann damit Freunde erschrecken oder verarschen oder was auch immer.
Was denn jetzt mit diesem Apple Remote? Damit wollen wir ein bisschen vorwärts kommen hier.
Ja, ich hab's nicht ausprobieren können, wie du dir vorstellen kannst, als nicht iPhone und nicht iPod Touch Besitzer.
Ich leider auch nicht.
Aber Word ist, es gibt jetzt eine Fernbedienung von Apple für iTunes auf dem Mac.
Ist aber auch erst runterladbar, ne? Ist nicht dabei, sondern muss man erst in den App Store runterladen.
Genau.
Das heißt, alle Zusatztools, die es jetzt von Apple geben wird, kommen per App Store, für umsonst dann. Oder?
Das wird sich zeigen, ob der schon ist, aber das ist auch noch was.
Aber sie hätten es ja auch gleich drauf packen können.
Klar, aber das Ding ist natürlich, diese Programme belegen auch Speicher.
Wenn mich nicht alles falsch.
So viel Speicher hast du halt nicht.
Stimmt, und hat auch nicht jeder einen Apple TV.
Also wir wissen nicht genau, wie das da drauf gekommen ist. Also wir haben ja vorhin das erste Mal ein iPhone 3G angeschlossen. Und da war eigentlich noch nicht synchronisiert. Also das Adressbuch war noch leer. Aber was drauf war, war AIM, Twitterrific und Remote. Also diese Programme. Kann sein, dass er die aus dem Backup irgendwie schon hergestellt hat. Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Aber kann auch sein, dass die einfach von vornherein quasi da drauf sind. Wie auf dem iPhone? Auf dem iPhone. Wenn man es kauft. 3G. Wenn man es kauft.
Kurze Frage. Die Firmware, also der hat ja, achso, nee, hat sich erledigt. Der hat ja einen 3G.
Genau. Und was wir gestern gemacht haben, ist diese noch nicht offizielle Firmware, die kursierte, also gab es, ist ja...
Ja, die ist nämlich 7 Megabyte größer.
Die ist nämlich etwas, achso, ja, das ist ja natürlich, das natürlich mal...
Da muss man nämlich aufpassen. Weil die von gestern heißt auf iPhone 1,2 und die offizielle, die heute rausgekommen ist, heißt iPhone 1,1 plus den hinten Diversionsnummer und so weiter. Aber die von gestern ist halt eben 7 Megabyte größer. Und nur eine andere Komprimierung kann ich mir eigentlich nicht so vorstellen, weil was soll denn da großartig anders sein? Irgendwas muss sich ja geändert haben, sonst wäre die Komprimierung ja gleich.
Also keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall die Firmware von gestern lief auf dem klassischen iPhone wie eine 1. Der App Store lief, es funktionierte alles. Was sehr angenehm ist übrigens, neue Programme gibt es noch nicht, aber die, die da sind, haben sich ein bisschen gebessert, was beim Safari-Browser unglaublich ist. Der ist wirklich viel, viel, viel, viel schneller geworden. Also was zumindest passt, JavaScript-Ausführung, Geschwindigkeit. Ja klar, da haben wir ja drüber geredet. Ich glaube, der hat den schon drin, ziemlich sicher sogar.
Ist das nicht einfach nur das 3.1. Weil die haben ja auch den alten schon schneller gemacht. Aber ich glaube, der Squirrel-Fish ist glaube ich noch zu beta. Meine ich. Weiß ich nicht, aber sie haben ja schon bei dem 3.1 erheblich an Speed zugelegt, dadurch, dass sie den alten was krebt.
Also ich weiß es nicht, das müsste man auch optimiert haben.
Also wenn das so ist, ist es aber auch ein gutes Zeichen, weil dann heißt das, dass es dann noch schneller wird.
Muss man halt natürlich sehen, wie das dann auf dem Arm performt. Aber ich bin da eigentlich auch sehr zuversichtlich. Das haben wir ja schon ausführlich drüber gesprochen. Na gut, ich meine wir können jetzt hier lange durch die Upstore-Liste...
Stimmt, das Gürblerfische ist erst ein Monat alt.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist noch zu früh. Wir können jetzt hier lange darüber Mutmaßen. Ich weiß nicht, noch mal kurz zu diesem Remote, um dich nicht zu unterbrechen. Also was ich entscheidend finde, ist, das ist halt nicht nur für iTunes und Fernbedienung, sondern halt auch für Apple TV. Das macht natürlich schon ganz gut Sinn.
Ah, ich dachte, das ist nur für Apple TV. Sonst ist es auch für iTunes.
Du kannst das mit iTunes verbinden.
Du kannst es mit dein iTunes Fernsteuern. Im Prinzip holen Sie jetzt das nach, was irgendwie Sawling-Clicker schon vor 3, 4 Jahren gemacht hat. Da habe ich ja schon mit meinem Sohn Ericsson alles schön ferngesteuert und hatte Albumcover auf meinen Telefonen sichtbar und so weiter. Hervorragendes Tool eigentlich. Lange Zeit allerdings nicht mehr aktualisiert worden. Von daher ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten.
Nicht schlecht.
Und jetzt hat Apple im Prinzip das auch fürs iPhone.
Ich hoffe, es läuft auch mit fremden Shares in meinem iTunes. Ich hab ja mein iTunes-Verwalteter, mein Multi-AAPD, da kommt ja meine Musik her. Ich hoffe, das kann der auch. Dann wäre richtig schick.
Das wäre interessant zu wissen.
Werde ich wahrscheinlich bei der nächsten Sendung wissen, wenn dann bis dahin die iPhone-Deaf-Jungs mal aus der Tasche gekommen sind.
Ich hoffe, das wird heute noch was. Langsam wäre ich mal ungeduldig.
Was sich auch noch gebessert hat bei der 2.0-Software, ist, dass ihr wohl nach anfänglichem... Am Anfang haben sie es nicht so richtig gemacht, diese Secure Vibe oder Remote Vibe, um das Telefon komplett zu löschen. Das war wohl am Anfang mehr als gelöscht markiert.
Moment mal, Remote Vibe und Vibe ist ja noch ein Unterschied. Und Secure Vibe, da sind ja noch zwei verschiedene Sachen. Erkläre. Ich glaube, den Button, irgendwo muss hier ein Button sein, wo ich quasi alle Einstellungen löschen kann, wenn ich das Ding irgendwie keine Ahnung machen will.
Also da gibt es auch den Secure Vibe.
Bei der neuen Firmware gibt es den Secure Vibe, der dann irgendwie ein paar Stunden, also der braucht, wir haben vorhin ausgeführt, der hat wirklich anderthalb Stunden oder irgendwie sowas gebraucht. Das ging ewig. Weiß nicht, was der dazu sagt, wenn mittendrin der Akku leer wird. Und dann gibt es den Remote Vibe. Der Remote Vibe ist für Firmenkunden gedacht, dass wenn da jemand, oh ich hab mein iPhone verloren, was machen wir jetzt, dass da der Admin eine Tasse drücken kann und dann wird das Telefon gelöscht, egal wo es gerade ist. Und ist für den bösen, bösen Hacker zumindest was. Oder nicht Hacker, Dieb. Für den Dieb zumindest die Daten umbrauchbar. Und der hat wirklich nur das Telefon. Damit keine Firmen Daten fangen können. Und das wird wahrscheinlich eine Kombination aus beiden Seiten.
Ich schätze mal, dass auch dieser Remote Vibe dann secure ist.
Er wird erstmal so löschen und dann wird er anfangen danach...
Auf jeden Fall haben sie das nachgebessert.
Ich hab noch zwei Gimmicks, die die Leute mit einer iPhone 2.0 Software ausbilden können. Ich selber konnte sie noch nicht ausbilden. Und zwar das erste ist, man kann Screenshots machen, indem man die Home-Taste drückt und gleichzeitig oben den On-Off-Button. Hab ich gelesen?
Es gibt für gehackte iPhones einen Installer-Skript, mit dem man die eingebaute Screenshot-Funktion aktiviert, die wir noch mit Home-Button drücken und einmal den Klingelton-An-Klingelton-Aus-Button drücken.
Ich glaub, der war's. Oder so rum?
Nee, nee, jetzt ist es wirklich diese Log-Taste.
Test jetzt einfach aus, Home-Button und unten anderen Button und dann muss ein Screenshot durchgehen. So viele sehen es ja nicht. Und das zweite, was mich schon immer genervt hat, ist, wenn man mit der 1er-Software, wenn man surft zum Beispiel oder an der Liste ganz unten ist. Aber am Safari macht es sich am besten merkbar. Du bist ganz unten und du willst eigentlich in die Eingabe-Leiste. Du musst ganz umständlich wieder nach oben scrollen und dafür kann man in der iPhone 2.0-Software oben in die Status-Leiste klicken und dann scrollt er automatisch bis ganz nach oben durch.
Aber bei den anderen Programmen geht es jetzt erst.
Das wusste ich auch noch nicht. Ich habe mal wieder was gelernt.
Was ich ja heute das erste Mal überhaupt oder gestern das erste Mal überhaupt entdeckt hätte, hätte ich gestern schon die 2.0-Firmware gehabt, hätte ich es darauf geschoben, wenn man zweimal die Home-Taste drückt, während man im Log-Screen ist, hat man kurzerhand eine iPhone-Steuerung, eine iPod-Steuerung.
Achso, das haben wir schon letztes Mal erzählt, oder? Nee, das wussten wir schon.
Ich wusste es noch nicht. Also auch bei altem iPhone viele neue Features. Ja, so.
Das war es jetzt aber.
Ja, also mit dem Upstore, da tun sich natürlich jetzt noch eine ganze Menge Fragezeichen auf. Die Developer sind ja auch schon am sich beklagen, weil sie viele Sachen nicht machen können, die sie vorher schon tun konnten. Also sie haben keine Möglichkeit, Freebies rauszugeben. Also zum Beispiel jetzt so Twitterrific gibt's halt jetzt zweimal im Upstore, einmal in frei und einmal in zu bezahlen. Weil du halt nur einen Preispunkt dafür setzen kannst, aber du kannst halt keine Gutscheine zum Beispiel. Ist halt darüber auch nicht zu machen.
Oder man kann nicht zwei Wochen testen lassen oder so.
Genau. Du hast auch nicht diese typische Shareware-Ding mit irgendwie Benutzmal und später bezahlst du.
Das sind aber bestimmt Sachen, die noch irgendwann mal nachkommen werden. Geh ich mal fest von aus.
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob das wirklich auf jeden Fall kommen wird. Ich denke, dass Apple jetzt auch erstmal schauen wird, wie gut das jetzt läuft. Also zumindest Rutscheine werden bestimmt kommen. Ja, Rutscheine könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass das so ein Ding ist.
Wir werden es sehen. Wir brauchen ja nicht in die Glasskugel zu gucken.
Ja, das ist so eine Sache. Aber stellt sich natürlich dann auch wirklich die Frage, wie gut die Akzeptanz der Developer ist. Ich meine, sie haben natürlich wenig Alternativen. Und ich denke, es gibt da auch noch eine Menge zu verdienen. Ja, ja.
Um himmelswillig das Thema zu wechseln, ich hab jetzt quasi, weltexklusiv wird das jetzt hier angekündigt, doch über Twitter hab ich schon mal angekündigt, dass man mal testen soll. Ich hab letzte Woche angefangen, einen kleinen Twitter-Client zu schreiben für das iPhone. Und zwar als Web-Applikation. Also nicht, weil ich ja keinen Coco kann und so. Also als Web-Applikation. Ich finde ihn aber, er ist ganz hübsch geworden. Könnt ihr gerne mal ausprobieren und mir Feedback schicken. Und zwar unter a.edwin.net. Edwin mit Doppel-E hinten. A wie Alpha. Und Edwin soll das Programm heißen, nach meiner Katze, die an Doofheit verstorben ist vor drei Wochen.
A wie Alpha?
Alpha-Version.
Ach.
Weil die ist noch sehr frisch.
Edwin. E-D-W-I-N.
E-D-W-E-E-N. Weil mit I war natürlich schon alles weg. Quasi.
Jetzt war es dann Edwin. Jetzt habe ich es ganz verloren. Nochmal von vorne, bitte.
a.edwin.net Was kommt jetzt in die E-Mail-Adresse? Ne? Ne E-Mail-Adresse?
Das ist das, was ich gerade nicht mitbekommen habe. Eine URL hast du gerade angegeben.
Ich habe eine URL angegeben. Die gibt man in so einem Webbrowser ein. a.edwin.net a.edwin.net Hab ich es oft genug gesagt?
Ja.
Aber jetzt musst du noch kurz erzählen, warum deine Katze gestorben ist. Hast du gerade gesagt, die ist an Doofheit gestorben.
Jetzt will ich es aber wissen.
Ich weiß das auch schon ausführlich über Twitter. Ich wusste jetzt nicht, ob das so eine Kunstaktion ist, die du da machst.
Nee, meine Katze ist wirklich tot. Ich habe die wirklich im Garten begraben. Ich hatte zwei Katzen, jetzt ist es nur eine. Ein bisschen doof ist, dieses arme, einsame Fieder jetzt rumhängen zu haben. Es fängt an mit meiner Doofheit, also zwar kombiniertes Doofheit für den Kater Fatal, für mich traurig. Ich habe den irgendwann mal versehentlich ausgesperrt. Und der ist dann... Der hat dann zwar immer im Garten gesessen oder in der Nähe des Gartens. Ich habe den gehört nachts und der hat rumgesessen. Aber er hat sich nie getraut, wieder auf die Veranda zu kommen, dass ich ihn mal reinlassen konnte oder so was. Weil das ein extrem schissriges Tier ist. Und dann irgendwann habe ich ihn aus den Augen verloren. Und er hat offensichtlich im Keller gelebt. Und da ist er vermutlich an Rattengift verendet. Ganz elendig. Zwei Meter von meiner Wohnung. Ich wohne im Erdgeschoss direkt im Keller unter meiner Kirche. Also ich habe geheult, mit anderen Worten. Und darum, um der Katze jetzt ein Denkmal zu setzen, heißt dieser Twitter-Klein Edwin. Kriegt auch eine Katze als Logo. Das heißt eine Künstlerin schon.
Katzen-Content bei Mobamex.
Wer hätte das gedacht? Ein Feature, auf das bin ich exorbitant stolz, das ist, das kriegt man mit einer nativen App nicht hin. Ich hatte vorher schon gesagt, es gibt Features, die kann man mit einer Web-App haben, die kann man mit einem Nativen-Programm nicht. Und zwar, man kann auf dem Springboard beliebig viele Icons anlegen. Und zwar, ihr könnt auf den Namen einer Person klicken und tippen und könnt dann nur deren Tweets zeigen lassen oder nur eure Inbox, eure Direct-Message-Inbox. Und dann geht ihr über dieses kleine Plus-Icon und sagt, zum Homescreen hinzufügen. Und dann habt ihr ein eigenes Icon nur für eure Direct-Message-Inbox oder nur für eure Favoriten oder nur für die Tweets von einer besonderen Person. Und als besonderes Gimmick, das zeige ich jetzt einfach. Da kannst du nur ein Icon pro Programm anlegen. Und als besonderes kleines Feature, worauf ich sehr, sehr stolz bin, ist, wenn man von einer Person sich das Icon anlegt auf dem Springboard, dann nimmt er sogar dieses Icon der Person. Also wenn ich jetzt hier von Tobitop erwischt, dann habe ich seinen kleinen Springfield-Charakter im Springboard hängen als Icon. Und das ist einfach ein super Feature. Und das hat kein nativer Twitter-Kland.
Hammer!
Yes, ich bin so stolz.
Super. Und muss noch nicht mal im Upstore gelistet werden.
Muss noch nicht mal im Upstore. Und ich kann Porno einbauen, wenn ich will. Wow. Eines Tages.
Twitter-Porn.
Ich arbeite ja auch gerade im iPhone-Programm, aber ich darf ja nicht sagen, was ich mache. Und ich hab auch noch nichts zum Vorführen. Also ich hätte schon was zum Vorführen.
Hast du jetzt einen Twitter-Account mittlerweile? Nee.
Dafür seid ihr zuständig. Ich bin mehr so in einer anderen Liga.
Ach so.
Du bist die Liga der Nicht-Twitterer.
Ich bin doch hier der Technik-Typ. Ihr seid hier, Max ist der Web 2.0-Typ und so. Twitter und jeder neuer Scheiß. Und du bist irgendwie...
Der Neutrale Nichts Wisser in der Mitte. Ja, super. Du Technik-Typ. Dann kannst du mir gleich nochmal die DNS-Geschichte erklären.
Nee, kann ich nicht.
Ach komm, tu nicht so. Wie auch immer. Jetzt bleiben wir nochmal ein bisschen beim iPhone, damit wir das Thema auch abgehakt bekommen. ich hab eigentlich schon gar nichts mehr zum iPhone. Aber was natürlich jetzt dazugehört und was wohl eine der wackeligsten Launches war, die Apple jemals gestartet hat, ist MobileMe, die Umstellung von.Mac. Ich hatte mir extra noch ein.Mac-Account vor kurzem billig geschoppt, als der für 49 Euro im Angebot war. Weil ich mir dachte, mach ich das mal, test ich das mal ein Jahr. Hat's geklappt? Na ja, also das war sehr ruckelig. Lauf dieses Tages ging me.com mehrere Male hoch und wieder runter. Als es dann richtig lief, hatte ich leider nicht so viel Zeit, das zu machen. Eigentlich ist das Bier bei mir dieses System-Update, was Apple da angeboten hat, was dein.mec-Preference-Pane in MobileMe umbenennt und auch noch einen Versionssprung für die Mail-Applikation bereitstellt und noch ein paar andere Sachen, ein paar Frameworks patched, Syncing Framework und so weiter. Das ist bei mir noch nicht angeboten worden. Wieder am Software-Update, noch in der.mec-Preference-Pane, wie mir viele gesagt haben, wo es angeblich dann auch angeboten wird. Nein, MobileMe ist ja heute auch erst gestartet.
Ach so, bis Ende Juni sollte man gesynkt haben, oder irgendwie sowas, ne?
Ja, dieses Bookmark-Syncing-Feature haben sie sich jetzt irgendwie gespart. Und man meinten sie halt, da jetzt nichts verloren geht, sollen wir nochmal alles synken. Hab ich jetzt eh nicht benutzt. Ich synke eigentlich auch kaum, weil ich eigentlich gar keinen Interesse habe, jetzt mein Adressbuch-Inhalte und solche Sachen auf irgendwelchen amerikanischen Servern zu speichern. Das ist mir dann doch ein bisschen zu fishy. Da muss ich halt jetzt nochmal schauen. Mich interessiert eher diese Kalender-Synking-Geschichte, ob das hilfreich ist. Aber sie haben auf jeden Fall wieder enorm viele Umstellungsprobleme gehabt. Und das führt ja eine lange, lange Serie von Flops mit.Mac zurück. Also viele User klagen da über Instabilitäten und dass das Ding halt immer wieder down ist, was nicht gut ist für so einen Cloud-Service. Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie zuverlässig bei Google die Dienstleistungen angeboten werden, obwohl sie kostenlos sind, im Vergleich dazu dort Mac, wo du halt Geld bezahlst und ja, du hast so eine typische Telekom Experience, so mit irgendwie ja, in 99 Prozent der Fälle läuft's, das heißt so drei Tage im Jahr läuft's nicht. Das ist einfach nicht okay und ich verstehe nicht, warum sie da so große Probleme haben. Also die Umstellung hat sie auf jeden Fall viel Arbeit gekostet, das ist offensichtlich.
Wär mal sehen, wie's läuft, oder?
Übrigens wird von Mobile Me Internet Explorer 6 nicht mehr unterstützt. Also mit den Mobile Me Apps gibt's keine Unterstützung mehr für den alten Internet Explorer. Finde ich ganz interessant, das ist eigentlich der erste Webdienst, von dem ich gehört habe, dass sie jetzt so ganz bewusst sagen, Internet Explorer 6 ist alte Scheiße, das nehmen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Wobei ich glaube, ich hab irgendwas gelesen, dass ja jetzt für Windows XP, Service Pack 3 als Zwangsupdate kommt, egal was man gesagt hat oder nicht, und da ist ja glaube ich Internet Explorer 7 dann auch mit dabei. Das heißt, in den nächsten Wochen wird wahrscheinlich die Internet Explorer 6 präsentsnah zu null gehen.
Na ja, ob das wirklich null ist, da habe ich so meine Zweifel. Aber trotzdem haben sich die wenigsten getraut, wirklich zu sagen, ach, alte Microsoft-Software wollen wir nicht mehr haben. Also ich finde das ein interessanter Schritt.
Wie viele User sollten es denn aber sein? Ich meine, es sind doch alles Apple-User.
Wie?
Na, Mobile-View ist ja auch für Windows.
Ja, schon, aber...
Ja, na nichts, aber...
iPhone-User? Davon wird es bestimmt einige geben, die nicht Mac-User sind.
Die kommen ja aber jetzt erst dann.
Und die setzen halt von vornherein eben auf Internet Explorer 7. Was ich auch durchaus verstehen kann, weil mit 6 ist es sicherlich... Oh Gott, ich hab das böse Wort gesagt, sorry. Nein, es setzt sich langsam durch alles.
Oder Safari natürlich, kann man ja auch für Windows und Plan.
Ja, ich find den auch gut. Den Safari, nach wie vor, du doch auch. Willst du nicht was zur Safari loben, oder?
Das war hier dieser, weil beim Firefox ist ja so das Tolle, dass man so viele Plugins benutzen kann und jetzt natürlich auch super viele Adblocker. Und bei Safari hatte ich früher mal diesen Pith Helmet, diesen Safari Helm. Und aber irgendwie tut er nicht mehr richtig oder ich irgendwann war er, jedenfalls war er ein bisschen komisch, dann hab ich aufgehört, den zu benutzen. Vor allem bin ich halt so ein Webkit benutzt, also so ein Nightly-Bild von Safari-Nutzer. Und dann hat ein Freund mir letztens gesagt, ich soll mal den Safari Ad-Block ausprobieren. Habe ich gemacht, hat sich installiert und tut wunderbar. Ich hab erst dann leider danach festgestellt, sonst hätte ich ihn wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht benutzt, dass es auch nur so ein Input-Manager ist, oder wie die heißen, so ein Symbol nicht, aber es auf die gleiche Art und Weise funktioniert wie dieser Piss-Helmet auch. Und es ist wahrscheinlich wie alle Input-Manager auch in Snow Leopard nicht mehr unterstützt, bin mir noch nicht ganz so sicher. Aber die Anforderungen an so einen Input-Manager sind auf jeden Fall deutlich gestiegen. Also es muss die richtigen Rechte haben, es muss RUT gehören, es darf nicht mehr im System installiert sein, sondern darf nur noch bei einem User installiert sein und so weiter und so fort. Also sie mussten die Schrauben ein bisschen anziehen, weil man zu viel Blödsinn mitmachen konnte. Aber so funktioniert halt dieser Adblocker und der tut wunderbar. Ich hab da irgendwie englisch und deutsche Werbung als Spam irgendwie subscribiert und seitdem ist die weg. Also was ich eigentlich gerne hätte, damit halt nicht der Firefox so mit seinen Features davon zieht, wär eigentlich irgendeine Art Plug-in-Interface für den Safari, was halt legal ist.
Nicht nur das, auch für Mail-Up und viele andere Programme.
Auf jeden Fall. Das wär wirklich mal was Schönes. Ich hab jetzt aufgrund dieser Entwicklung mal wieder ein bisschen die Entwickler-Tools von Safari mir auch mal ein bisschen genauer angucken können, weil...
Welche Entwickler-Tools?
Die Developer-Konsole zum Beispiel. Die deutlich hübscher ist als Firebug, aber nicht ganz so gut nach wie vor. Also Firebug ist ein Plugin für Firefox, mit dem man nach Fehlern in seinem HTML-Code, seinem JavaScript-Code und seinem CSS-Code suchen kann.
Bei Safari ist es jetzt ja Build-in, ne?
Bei Safari ist es Build-in, den muss man einschalten über...
Dieses Debug-Menü, oder?
Genau, indem man das Debug-Menü einschaltet, dann hat man den Inspector, funktioniert relativ ähnlich, hat nicht ganz so viele Features, ist aber deutlich hübscher. Und was mir aufgefallen ist, da sind sie sehr stolz drauf, das gesamte User-Interface, was sehr Mac-like aussieht, ist komplett in HTML und man kann wieder mit der rechten Maustaste draufklicken und Inspect anklicken, kann sich angucken, wie haben die denn in HTML dieses Element gebastelt. Das ist eine sehr lustige Sache. Und Safari hat doch einige hübsche Features, die sonst kein Browser hat, die man, wenn man nur fürs iPhone entwickelt, auch gnadenlos nutzen kann. Also zum Beispiel, was normalerweise ein Problem ist, abgerundete Ecken. Das ist die billigste Sache der Welt. Kann Safari. Man kann sagen, mach die Ecken abgerundet. Habe ich auch heftigen Gebrauch von gemacht.
Da gibt es auch einen Blog-Eintrag bei blog.web.git.gov.org oder web.git.org.
Und es gibt auch die Geschichte, dass Steve Jobs bei Einführung des ersten Max so extrem darauf bestanden hat, dass er unbedingt... Ne, dass das eine Zeichenfunktion hat, mit der man Rechtecke mit abgerundeten Ecken zeichnen kann. Gibt's auf folkloro.org die Geschichte?
Mir fällt übrigens gerade auf, dass mein Leopard keine Runde Ecken mehr hat, oben im Menü.
Das hat Leopard nicht, genau.
Die Runde Ecken haben sie gekürzt.
Wir müssen eine Sondersendung machen.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Mit Mac OS 9 waren oben die Ecken abgerundet und unten.
Ja, und waren später nur noch oben.
Dann mit Mac OS 10 nur noch oben.
Was ich okay fand.
Was ich sehr, sehr hübsch fand auch. Und jetzt nur noch oben, gar nicht mehr.
Aber in 10.4 waren die noch da, die Runde?
In 10.4 waren die noch da, ja.
Das war mal ein bisschen irritierend, weil sie haben es ja so gemacht, dass man sowohl Spotlight als auch das Abfüllmenü bis in die Ecke fahren kann. Das heißt, man muss sich keine Sorgen machen, dass man richtig trifft. Sondern man konnte wirklich bis in die Ecke fahren, da wo das Menüsymbol eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr ist. Aber trotzdem, wenn man klickt, dann Spotlight oder das Abfüllmenü kommt. Und da war natürlich, wenn da diese runde Ecke war, war natürlich schwarz an der Stelle. Und dann war es noch unlogischer da, dass dann trotzdem das Menü erscheint. Vielleicht haben sie es deswegen weggenommen.
Also mir ist nicht so ganz klar, warum sie es weggenommen haben.
Ich glaube, das ist so eine Designfrage.
Ich meine, ich lebe jetzt nicht schlechter seitdem. Das ist eine Designfrage.
Aber ich meine, wir haben mit dem Update sechs Pixel dazubekommen. Das ist, ähm, sechs?
Sechs, nein, mehr Pixel.
Linkswins 3 würde ich mal behaupten gewesen.
Nee, das sind mehr.
Aber das Menü ist ja nicht kleiner dadurch.
Nein, das war, ähm, tut mir leid, ich hab versucht, einen Witz zu machen. Ja, aber auf jeden Fall...
Wir sind ja hier, es ist ja ein Podcast, wir sind ja nicht zum Spaß hier.
Ach so, ach so.
Ah! So ist es ja nicht. Aber, Brodo jetzt gerade, ähm, sagst mit hier, äh, bei dem Web-Developer, wie heißt das noch gleich?
Der Inspector.
Wobei Inspector, den kann man auch so...
Saja, alles hat den Mail- und Jüller-Interface. Jetzt kommt der Knaller. Apple hat ein iPhone-Config-Web-Utility-Released. Jetzt zusammen mit, äh, haben tatsächlich zwei Utilities gemacht. Das eine ist so für den Enterprise-Bereich. Für den Enterprise-Bereich, wo sozusagen du in der Firma, wenn du jetzt so deine ganze Handelsflotte mit iPhones ausgestattet hast, dass du halt zentral alles machen kannst. Und das iPhone-Configuration-Web-Utility 1.0, was es sowohl für den Mac als auch für Windows gibt. Ich hab's noch nicht so richtig ausprobiert. Damit kann man aber Configuration-Files machen, mit dem du halt so VPN-Settings, Wi-Fi-Settings, APN-Settings, Exchange-Account-Settings und diesen ganzen Kram machen kannst, um halt schnell über einen Web-Browser diese Settings zu verbreiten, dass sozusagen die Leute in der Firma sagen können, ok, hier ist mein Setup für die Firma, wo alles drin ist.
Das heißt, ich gehe dann in meinem iPhone auf eine Webseite und dann werden die Einstellungen runtergeladen, oder wie?
Ich hab das nicht ausprobiert, weil ich es nicht ausprobieren kann.
Das ist halt, dass ein Admin für seine 100 Angestellten irgendwie die schon vorkonfigurieren kann, weil die Angestellten haben ja wie immer keine Ahnung, schon gar nicht, was VPNs angeht.
Aber mit Zertifikaten und diesem ganzen Super Pro. Die Tatsache, dass es dieses Tool gibt, finde ich schon mal bemerkenswert. Was aber noch bemerkenswerter ist, worin dieses Tool programmiert ist. Es handelt sich bei diesem Programm, was du runterlädst. Das ist eine normale Application, die irgendwie auf deinem Computer ist. Und wenn du sie startest, startet dir ein Web-Server. Ach, es handelt sich um eine Ruby-on-Rails-Anwendung, die mit Sprout Core arbeitet. Und damit machen sie ihre Cross-Plattform Tool Delivery.
Weil es zu Windows und für Mac gibt.
Wir erinnern uns, letzte Sendung, unsere Diskussion. Ich schick dir mal einen Link. Schick mir einen GIF. Schick mir einen GIF. Bist du überhaupt irgendwo online?
Ich bin an diversen Stellen online.
Mach dir das mal klar, dann kann ich ja in der Zwischenzeit erzählen, weil du hattest ja glaub ich in der Vorherigen...
Warte mal, ich wollte das nochmal kurz zu Ende führen. Also die starten tatsächlich auf dem Mac den Mongrel Robi-Webserver und auf dem Windows den alten Webbrick. Warum sie jetzt auf Windows noch den alten nehmen und auf dem Mac den neuen weiß ich nicht. Aber ich finde es ja erstaunlich, dass diese Cross-Plattform-Problematik an der Stelle, dass sie das Tool halt sowohl auf Windows als auch auf Mac zum Laufen kriegen müssen, jetzt darüber lösen. Also man macht irgendwie auf Port 3000 macht er seinen Webserver drauf und dann connectet er da drauf.
Ist natürlich mal ein interessantes Experiment, muss man auf jeden Fall sagen.
Und zeigt das Apple, dass man selber jetzt benutzt, dieses Proudcore. Ich meine, wir haben ja drüber geredet, dass sie das gefeaturet haben.
Sieht das denn Mac OS X-Lucky aus?
Kannst du ja einfach mal kurz runterladen und starten.
Das finde ich, so was finde ich wirklich sau spannend. Kann jemand von euch Ruby und Rails ein bisschen? Also ein bisschen kann ich auch.
Jetzt aber.
Ich werde gerade gebeten, die Gehörer von Torsten zu größen, dann mache ich das.
Vor der letzten Sendung, sondern nach vorletzter Sendung, vielleicht sogar schon noch länger, hast du dir mal von diesem iVPN-Tool erzählt, was irgendwie die Funktionalität von Mac OS X Server, vom VPN-Tool auf das normale Mac OS X irgendwie bringt. Und ich habe damit ein bisschen rumgespielt und es hat sich mit meinem iPhone irgendwie verbunden, aber die Connections wollten alle nicht durch dieses VPN-Tool durchgehen, obwohl ich auf dem iPhone gesagt habe, dass es es für alle Connections benutzen soll. Der Trick ist, also wenn man es dann erst mal eingestellt hat, müsst ihr euch natürlich ein bisschen reinfummeln, dass man bei diesem Tool als Netzmaske 0.0.0.0 angeben muss und dann wird auch alles wirklich durchgeleitet und es funktioniert wunderbar. Weil das ist ja so eine PPP-Verbindung und das Tool sagt dem iPhone wahrscheinlich, für welches Netz es zuständig ist. Und ich sag diesem iVPN-Tool, dass es halt für alles zuständig ist und dann wird es vom iPhone auch so benutzt. Warum dann beim iPhone der Button, das alles irgendwie da drüber zu machen, es nicht funktioniert, obwohl ich es angebe, ist mir ein bisschen unklar, aber wenn man es dann bei dem iVPN-Tool richtig einstellt, dann geht es auch. Das ist auf jeden Fall schick. So, jetzt aber, nächstes Thema.
Nächstes Thema?
Nächstes Thema.
Ja, iPhone haben wir jetzt irgendwie abgedingstbumst. Es gibt Gerüchte. Wollen wir über Gerüchte reden?
Ich dachte, wir werden, weil du so schön von Corporate angefangen hast und du wolltest ja nochmal auf ein Thema eingehen.
Genau.
Von dem ich...
Du meinst Axel?
Axel, eine Rudi-Dutschke-Firma.
Die Firma aus der Rudi-Dutschke-Straße.
Axel Springer, die fast so unbeliebt ist wie Axel Schweiß. Jetzt wollte ich den schlechten Wort machen. Du hast den besseren gemacht.
Also, der Axel Springer Verlag stellt um auf Max, nicht auf Mac OS X, aber auf Max.
Also auf die Hardware. Und soweit es geht wohl auch auf die Software.
Soweit es geht. Aber da wo es nicht geht, können sie halt auch noch Windows fahren.
Solange der User dann keinen Bock mehr hat und dann sofort switchen kann, ohne seinen Rechner wechseln zu müssen.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie das mit einem Fischy-YouTube-Video angekündigt, wo dann so ein Oberhansel einen erzählt hat, warum sie jetzt umstellen. Und es war echt interessant. Der hat da vier oder fünf Gründe genannt. Die ersten drei waren so was wie Max sehen hübscher aus und sind total trendy. Und dann erst der vierte Punkt war naja, das kommt uns auch billiger. Das ist auch mal was ganz Neues fürs Business. Dass der Aspekt, es ist billiger, auf Platz vier landet. Während es hübscher vorher ist. Und er also ganz offensichtlich vollkommen eingenommen war von ihrer Entscheidung. Es ist so toll, dass wir jetzt Max haben. Sie werden sich sicherlich alle total freuen. Und alles so großartig. Und sie kriegen iPhones.
Und sie kriegen alle iPhones.
Ich glaube, das war wahrscheinlich auch eine strategische Entscheidung. Was wir wirklich gesehen haben, dass sie mit dem iPhone da eine Verbindung herstellen können zwischen ihren internen Verlagsabläufen.
Und den mobilen Anwendern. Aber ich glaube auch, dass das so ein bisschen aus so ist, dass natürlich der Vorstandsvorsitzende gerne ein iPhone hätte und nicht mehr mit einem blöden Blackberry rumrennen will.
Ja gut, aber das kann der Vorstandsvorsitzende sowieso machen.
Ja, aber wenn die ganze Firma noch dazu passt, dann kann man sagen, wenn man Mitarbeiter anwirbt, dann kann man sagen, guckt mal, dazu gibt's ein lustiges iPhone, wenn ihr bei uns arbeitet.
Aber wir alle wissen, Axel Springer ist nicht dazu da, um irgendwie die Welt besser zu machen. Axel Springer ist dazu da, um Geld zu verdienen. Und die werden sich das schon gut überlegt haben. Zumindest müssen sie es hart durchargumentieren, um das dann auch wirklich so durchzusetzen. Weil ich bin mir sicher, dass es auch eine ganze Menge Stimmen gegeben hat.
Also intern war das mit dem ist billiger schon auf Platz 1, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, das ähm, oder zumindest ist es... Ja, ich meine, die Berechnung hätte ich ja ganz gerne mal gesehen. Aber am Ende hatten sie wahrscheinlich einfach Schnauze voll von ihren ganzen zusammengeschraubten PCs.
Aber es ist auch nicht so, dass sie jetzt, sie sagen, wir haben 10.000 Angestellte, was, da hast du von heute auf morgen 10.000 Rechner bestellen, sondern die migrieren ja über die nächsten Jahre bis 2013 oder was stand da?
Ja sicher, das könnte Apple auch gar nicht liefern. Stell dir mal vor, du wirst da auf ein iPhone, äh, in Apple Store gehen und sagen hier, ich hätte gerne mal 10.000, äh, 5.000 iMacs, 2.000 Mac Pros und... Wo das Problem ist?
Na guck dir mal die Rollouts als Roll... Bei amerikanischen Unis an, die machen auch genau das jeden Sommer.
Ja gut, aber das ist in den USA.
Ja und?
Ja, hier rechnen die nicht damit. Das bringt jetzt gar nichts.
Ja, wenn die sagen, wir wollen in drei Monaten 10.000 Rechner haben, dann kriegen sie die, glaube ich.
Wir probieren das einfach mal aus, denn ich würde sagen, wir bestellen jetzt einfach mal 10.000 Laptops und gucken, wann die kommen.
Wie war das hier mit dieser Cluster-Geschichte? Schaut mal auf www.apple.de Virginia-Geschichte?
Gibt es mal kurz eine Kreditkarte?
Ja, aber da sind die auch erstmal zu Apple hingegangen und gesagt, wir haben ein tolles Projekt und wollten uns nicht mal unterstützen. Dann haben die gesagt, tolle PR und so. Na klar, das haben die auch bei Axel Sprenger gemacht. Ich habe auch keinen Zweifel, dass sie ihre Büchsen kriegen werden und überhaupt verkauft Apple ganz gut. 50% Marktwachs insgesamt und über 60% bei den Laptops. Das ist ein Vielfaches von dem, was die anderen Firmen haben. Da freut sich doch der Fanboy. Ich bin ja ein Fanboy. Wusstest du das?
Ja, also ich ahnte das zumindest.
Du ahntest das schon?
Ja, also Apple ist evil.
Nein, das kannst du doch so nicht sagen.
Denn es ist unser böser Anti-Fanboy.
Echt, ich dachte du wärst das.
Ich? Nein, wieso? Wer von uns hier hat eigentlich kein iPhone? Genau.
Aber du hast Firefox gut gefunden.
Also ich hab gewonnen.
Aber auf dem Mac.
Ich hab gewonnen.
Aber du sagst doch immer Apple ist evil. Ich meine, ist hier jede Sendung zu behaupten?
Weil man mit dem Adressbuch keine SMS macht.
Apple ist evil, solange sie diese Services im Betriebssystem belassen. Das ist wirklich der leidigste und ekligste Dienst überhaupt. Das ist so eine Frechheit. Ja, ich meine, leid ist da nicht darunter. Das fällt mir jeden Tag ins Gesicht.
Nee.
Was?
Ich hab die sogenannte...
Services. Hab ich da nicht schonmal drüber geredet? Services, genau, das was im jeweiligen Applikationsnamenmenü einen eigenen Punkt vertreten ist. Ja, das ist ein Next-Ding, das ist scheiße. Guck dir das da mal an, wie viele Shortcuts sich da installiert haben, mit denen, die du nie zugestimmt hast. Und die sind global. Das heißt, jedes Programm, was du installierst, und du dragst es einfach nur auf die Platte. Und in dem Moment hast du einen neuen Shortcut, der alles überlagert. So, und da halt die Shortcuts auch in der jeweiligen Lokalisierung unterschiedlich sind. Also auf der deutschen Tastatur zum Beispiel.
It's a mess, willst du das sagen.
Meine Lieblingskeyboard-Shortcut, den ich den ganzen Tag benutze, ist Apfel kleiner und Apfel shift kleiner. Das ist für mich das Produktivitätsdruck.
Also zwischen Fenstern hin und her schalten.
Genau, zwischen Fenstern einer Applikation hin und her schalten.
Darf ich da mal einen schönen Tipp geben?
Nee, ich will das erst zu Ende erzählen.
Gut, mach das.
Du kennst aber diesen Shortcut.
Ich kenne diesen Shortcut, aber ich hab da noch...
So, damit kann man schön durchblättern. Und ich weiß einfach immer, ich arbeite mit Abhorm. Na, eigentlich geht das in Safari, aber du hast wahrscheinlich auch wieder irgend so ein Tool installiert.
Was das überlädt, meinst du?
Was das einfach überlädt. Wie zum Beispiel Omni Outlier. Das ist zum Beispiel so ein Frechdachs. Und dann drücke ich irgendwie das. Und also manchmal ist es so, dass es dann nicht mehr funktioniert, weil der Shortcut ist irgendwie reserviert, aber der Service ist gerade nicht aktiv, weil du ja gar nichts detektiert hast, aber der nimmt sich trotzdem den Shortcut und dann geht es einfach nicht mehr. Oder noch schlimmer, er überlädt es halt mit einer anderen Funktionalität. Ich blätter halt rückwärts durch die Fenster und dann startet sich auf einmal Omni Outliner Pro, nimmt die aktuelle Selektion des Programms und tut mir das in irgendeine neue Outline rein. Was ich einfach nicht will. Früher gab es das tolle Tool Service-Krabber, das gibt es immer noch. Und immer das erste, was ich gemacht habe, wenn ich mal wieder neue Programme installiert habe, ist durchzugehen und einfach alles ausschalten. Aus, aus, aus, aus, aus und save. Und das habe ich dann halt bei Leopard nach der Neuinstallation auch gemacht. Und da hatte ich ja so eine Weile Ärger. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch, dass bei mir die Programme nicht auf die Keychain zugreifen konnten. Safari und Mail und so weiter. Und das lag da dran, dass ich mit dem Service-Grabber diese Services ausgeschaltet habe, was ich nämlich nicht so richtig begriffen hatte.
Das hast du im Vergleich beim nächsten Thema schon.
Die haben nämlich in das Bundle reingeschrieben, haben die Config geändert und dadurch war das Code-Signing gebrochen. Und dadurch, dass das Code-Signing gebrochen war, funktionierte der Zugriff auf die Keychain nicht mehr.
Ich hatte damit mal ganz schlechte Erfahrungen.
Ist das nicht krass? Du musst jetzt erst mal dein, du musst jetzt einfach sowas sagen wie das ist ja wirklich eklig, Tim.
Es ist unglaublich. Ich kann noch einen Beitrag dazu beileisten, dass es nochmal ganz furchtbarer ist. Weil zum Beispiel gibt es nämlich, ich weiß nicht mehr welches Programm, ich glaube ich hab's dann einfach gelöscht. Das hat nämlich im System-Menü, genau im Dienst-Menü etwas eingebaut. Im Services-Menü. Dienstes auf Deutsch. Dass auf die Tasten-Kombination Apfel-Alt reagierte. Wie? Nur Apfel-Alt? Quatsch Apfel-Alt. Apfel-Alt-Zeichen. Das war die Tasten-Kombination dafür. Apfel-Alt.
Apfel-Alt-L.
Auf einer deutschen Tastatur. Das führte dazu, dass in Safari das Download-Fenster nicht mehr aufging, sondern stattdessen dieser Menübefehl ausgeführt wurde. Von dem ich aber nicht wusste, was macht er, weil ich keine Ahnung hatte, dass er überhaupt existierte. Er funktionierte schlicht und ergreifend nie, weil man einen bestimmten Text ausgewählt haben. Es gab einfach nur ein Beep. Jedes Mal, wenn ich das Download-Fenster in Safari aufmachen wollte, hatte ich nur ein kurzes Beep. Kriegt mal jemand raus, dass da ein System...
Genau, das ist die totale Usability-Hölle. Du sagst doch auch gerade, im Safari geht das ja gar nicht mit den Blättern. Das liegt nämlich genau an so einem Scheiß-Service.
Ich kenne dieses Feature gar nicht, weil es ja nie ging.
Genau.
Das ist ja genau das, was ich schon immer brauche. Selbst der Amiga konnte Fenster irgendwie nach hinten legen. Und, Entschuldigung, aber...
Ja, also ich navigiere nur mit Alptap und mit Apfel kleiner Größe. Das ist für mich die, wie ich das nenne. Deswegen benutze ich auch Exposé nicht. Zum Beispiel. Und Spaces auch nicht.
Exposé muss ich auch nicht.
Komm nur damit klar, weil ich immer weiß, wonach ich suche.
Also was ich ja da empfehle...
Also unsere Leser, Hörer sollen uns mal schreiben, wie man dieses Service-Menü irgendwie systemkonform entfernen kann. Plus die Shortcuts dafür natürlich.
Ja, und dann auch am besten gleich Apple mal schreiben, wie sie... und denen zu erklären, wie sie mal dieses Service-Menü entfernen können.
Ist das nicht ein Service? Ist das nicht ein Framework? Kann man das nicht einfach wegschmeißen? Dann müssen die Programme nur noch lernen, dass sie klarkommen, wenn es nicht da ist.
Keine Ahnung, das gehört ganz tief mit in das ganze Aqua-User-Interface. Und das ist ein Standard-Virtual-Air-Programme.
Ich hab gesagt, der liest alle Mails.
Aha, steveatapple.com?
Auch die mit Niagara entfangen.
Services müssen sterben.
Haben wir jetzt einen Titel schon wieder, diese Sendung?
Also ich glaube, aber nur wenn du es mit drei Ausrufezeichen und mindestens vier Einzeln schreibst.
Oder Runde Ecken, gucken wir mal.
Aber die Runde-Ecken-Geschichte, genau, die wollte ich eigentlich, die kann man auch schön mal erzählen. Aber um jetzt...
Runde Ecken ist schön.
Dass Steve Jobs tatsächlich...
Hab ich auch erzählt vorhin.
Habe ich erzählt? Weißte. Dass die Entwickler das nicht machen wollten, die hatten keinen Bock darauf, auf diese abgerundeten Ecken. Daraufhin ist er losgezogen, Steve Jobs, und hat am nächsten Tag einen Vortrag gehalten, dass er draußen in der Welt geguckt hat, und was da draußen alles Runde Ecken hat. Darum braucht auch der Mac...
Was denn?
In seinen Quick-Draw-Routinen, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, Runde Ecken. Und daraufhin musste er sich in einen armen Entwickler hinsetzen und musste diese runden Ecken implementieren.
Was hat denn runde Ecken in der Welt?
Na zum Beispiel, guck mal hier zum Beispiel, Mac Pro hat hier... Das ist ja auch von Steve.
Das ist ja auch von Steve.
Und, ähm, stimmt das, aber guck mal, viele Apple-Produkte, das iPhone hat abgerundete Ecken, das ist auch von Steve.
Jedes Telefon hat abgerundete Ecken.
Der liebt runde Ecken und ich würde behaupten, in WebKit diese Funktion für die abgerundeten Ecken gibt es auch, weil Steve Jobs gesagt hat, hey, im Web gibt es so wenig abgerundete Ecken und daraufhin wurden abgerundete Ecken eingebaut.
Aber was hat denn in der normalen Welt abgerundete Ecken?
Mein Apfel.
Ja zum Beispiel guck mal, die Festplatte, die da rumliegt, ist nicht von Apple. Also ich meine, hier in diesem Raum, was normale Welt ist, in diesem Raum ist nichts normale Welt. Guck mal deine Backup-Festplatte, da hat es zum Beispiel abgerundete Ecken.
Ich finde das ein bisschen weit hergeholt. Ich glaube nicht, dass er mit Backup-Platten argumentiert hat.
Ich suche den Artikel mal raus, vielleicht steht da ja noch was drin. Aber noch ganz kurz zum Thema Application-Switcher. Wir wollten ja immer so tolle Programme ansprechen. Es gibt ein Programm, das heißt Witch. Damit kann man auch ganz toll sich Tasten-Kombinationen zulegen, um zwischen Fenstern hin und her zu wechseln. So richtig wie mit so einem Apfel-Tap, wo man ja zwischen einzelnen Programmen hin und her...
Witch wie Hexe.
Costed war bis vor kurzem kostenlos. Costed jetzt 9,95 Euro in Version 2, was ich mir sofort gekauft habe. Sehr tolles Programm, kann ich nur empfehlen. Gerade wenn man zum Beispiel, so wie ich, ungefähr 48 Millionen BB-Edit-Fenster immer offen hat. Ein großartiges Programm. Weil man sieht auch, wo das Fenster ist. Das nächste, was man offen hat, sind gut angelegte 10 Euro. Das zeige ich dir mal kurz. Das sieht doch richtig hübsch aus. Das sind jetzt alle Fenster eines Programms, was ich jetzt hier hauptsächlich verwende. Man kann aber auch Tastenkombinationen einstellen.
Mit so einem Bezel, der dann eingeblendet wird.
Genau, sieht aus, als ob es von Apple kommen würde.
Hat auch runde Ecken.
Ich hatte das irgendwann mal installiert.
Das war früher ein bisschen langsam und ein bisschen träger und ich hab's nicht so wirklich gemocht. Mittlerweile, spätestens seit Version 2, ist das richtig schnell.
10 Euro.
9,95 Euro. Kann man mal machen.
Wo wir jetzt gerade bei dem Thema sind, kann ich auch gleich mein wichtigstes Tool nochmal erfolgen.
Ihr seid mir ja zu schnell heute. Ach du willst auch was sagen? Du hast ja gerade von diesem Codesign erzählt. Wir hatten noch eine Unterhaltung darüber, wo wir das nachgeforscht haben. Müssen wir eigentlich noch was hinterher erzählen?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was hinterhergeforscht haben, von was. Wie das mit dem Codesign funktioniert.
Dass eigentlich auch schon alle Applikationen auf dem Leopard Codesign sind und das, wenn man in das Programm reingeht. Jetzt muss ich ein bisschen klicken schnell. Hier in Show Package Contents. Dort gibt es den Ordner Contents. Und da drin gibt es immer eine Datei Code Resources. Und das ist ein riesen XML-File, wo die ganzen Hashes über die einzelnen Dateien, Bundles und sonst wie sind. Und wenn das nicht mehr hinhaut, dann kann zum Beispiel das entsprechende Programm nicht mehr so wie vorher auf die Keychain zugreifen. Da wäre zum Beispiel die Frage, ob man erst sein Programm umpatcht und danach damit die Keychain benutzt. Also greift es dann mit einer anderen ID auf die Keychain zu oder?
Ich hab das nicht so ganz verstanden, muss ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt.
Was ich gerade gesagt hab oder? Na du hast Programm, hat einen bestimmten Hasch und das trägt was in die Keychain ein. Danach änderst du das Programm, das kriegt einen anderen Hasch dadurch und kommt deswegen an den alten Keychain-Eintrag nicht mehr ran. Wenn du das Programm erst patcht und gleich mit diesem neuen Hasch sozusagen anfängst, ob man dann mit der Keychain keine Probleme mehr hätte.
Aber zu welchen Zeiten? Also gesigned wird das Programm doch vom Programmierer?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo es kommt, ist es ja sozusagen schon gesigned. Und wenn ich dann nachträglich die Konfiguration ändere, dann ist es halt...
Na wahrscheinlich kannst du dir einen eigenen Schlüssel besorgen und es wieder neu signen. Indem du zum Beispiel einen Schlüssel, der da ist, wegschmeißt.
Das meinte ich gerade nicht mal. Aber du kannst ja auch mit nicht signierten Programmen irgendwie auf die Keychain zugreifen. Das ist doch nur so, dass die Keychain sich beschwert, wenn sich das Programm geändert hat, dass es dann das Programm nicht mehr anlässt. Wenn du aber den Patch vorher machst, bevor du auf die Keychain zum ersten Mal zugreifst, dann merkt die Keychain ja gar nicht, dass du es geändert hast.
Da steht aber immer noch im Bundle drin, dass dieses Programm eigentlich mal gesigned war und jetzt nicht mehr passt.
Und diese Information müsste man wahrscheinlich löschen.
Aber benutzen kann man es ja trotzdem. Deswegen müsste man mal noch ein bisschen weiter forschen.
Ja, man kann es immer noch benutzen, das stimmt. Es ist nicht so, dass er Alarm schlägt und sagt, dieses Programm wurde verändert.
Und kann man noch neue Keychain-Einträge damit machen?
Das ist mir nicht gelungen.
Also man kann keinen neuen mehr machen. Dann geht es natürlich nicht.
Man kann auch auf die alten nicht zugreifen.
Aber man kann vielleicht dieses Signing komplett rauslöschen, dass es jemals gesigned war, das müsste ja gehen.
Du kannst ja diese Code-Resources-Datei einfach löschen.
Mal Spaßes haben und gucken, was dann passiert. Aber auf jeden Fall, das Service-Menü muss sterben. Ich finde, das ist definitiv ein schöner Titel für die Sendung. Und? Oder Runde Ecken.
Aber nochmal ein kleiner Tipp, wenn interessiert, welche Programme auf seinem Rechner gesigned sind. Da kann man das Programm Codesign aufrufen. Das ist standardmäßig dabei. Terminal ist das Programm? Genau, im Terminal.
Das ist die Commandline?
Ihr müsst euch in die Untiefen des Unix vorstoßen. Also Codesign, minus D, minus Leerzeichen und dann der Pfad des Application-Bundles. Und jetzt habe ich hier mal so eine kleine Schleife gemacht, die über den ganzen Application-Ordner rübergeht und abgesehen von den ganzen standardmäßig mit Mac OS X ausgelieferten Programmen, gibt es tatsächlich auch schon so einige andere Programme, die gesigned sind. Und zu meiner größten Überraschung, vor allem, sind Open Source-Programme hier dabei. Also Adium kommt gesigned und CyberDuck kommt gesigned und Xpandrive, ist jetzt nicht Shareware, ist auch gesigned, ITV, OmniPlan, OmniWeb, der Reelplayer interessanterweise auch, ScreenFlow, ScreenRecycler, S-Life, ich sag jetzt nur die, die jetzt hier nicht Standard sind. Turbo 264 ist der Treiber für diesen komischen Encoding-Beschleuniger, benutze ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Das ist ein USB-H264-Beschleuniger.
Genau, da hab ich hier so einen rumgammeln. Die liegt jetzt hier noch auf dem Rechner, ich benutze das hier nicht wirklich. Und Zatue hier, dieses Internet-Fernseh-Dingsbumms, ist auch gesigned, also es gibt so diverse Tools, die das schon benutzen. Aber viele benutzen es vor allem auch nicht.
Na Zatue wahrscheinlich muss man nicht gesigned sein, damit man automatisiert aus der Firewall mit der Firewall nach außen geöffnet werden darf mittlerweile. Und Zatue ist ja so peer-to-peer-basiert, wenn ich nicht alles täusche. Das heißt, die werden sich ja Löcher ohne Ende durch die Firewall bohren müssen.
Ah, gut, dass du das erwähnst mit der Firewall. Ist es nicht sogar so, dass wenn man ein Programm für die Firewall freischaltet, dass es dann on demand gesigned wird, wenn es noch nicht gesigned ist?
Stimmt, irgendwie so was war da.
Vielleicht sind nämlich die gar nicht ab Werk gesigned, sondern nur deshalb, weil ich meine Firewall hier mal so eingestellt habe. Ne, Skype ist definitiv gesigned und Adion ist definitiv auch schon ab Hersteller gesigned.
Aber sind natürlich beides auch Programme, die dazu geneigt sind, auch mal die Firewall zu probieren.
Forschungspotenzial, ne? Ich hätte das auch gerade gar nicht so eingestellt. Also es ist auf jeden Fall noch interessant, wie weit das geht.
Es ist sehr schlecht, wobei es natürlich auch, ich will nicht gar nicht zum iPhone zurück, aber...
Ja, da gibt es natürlich viel Diskussion darüber, ne?
Aber an sich finde ich das jetzt erst mal nicht verkehrt, wenn ich sicher sein kann, dass das Programm, so wie ich es bekommen habe, auch noch ist.
Ja, es ist ein totales Security-Feature. Es bietet durchaus die Möglichkeit, eine sichere Plattform zu machen, wenn du deinen Rechner zu einem Zeitpunkt x-mal so durchsignen kannst. Also auch, dass man sozusagen sagen kann, diese Applikationen werden jetzt so as-is, hier jetzt lokal gesigned. Und wenn irgendwas sich verändert, dann darf es nicht mehr gestartet werden. Das wäre mal ganz interessant. Aber dann müssen natürlich solche Sachen wie Input-Manager, die sich an Demand beim Starten des Programms einklinken, die müssten dann natürlich dann verboten werden. Dann würden so Tools wie One Passwort, ein Safari-Adblock. Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich auch eine gute Idee. Dann muss man aber eben auch sehen, wie das mit Plugins funktioniert. Weil die Plugins letzten Endes auch ähnlich funktionieren.
Und für den Endanwender kann das natürlich auch eine Einschränkung bedeuten.
Klar, aber Security bedeutet immer eine Einschränkung.
Aber auch Seiten des Herstellers. Also Apple könnte dann auch Dinge machen, dass während der DVD-Player läuft, dass dann nur noch gesignete Applikationen gleichzeitig laufen dürfen.
Ja, aber das ist eben diese hätte-könnte müsste-Diskussion, die schon seit Ewigkeiten geführt wird. Mit diesem Ja und Apple hätte ja die Möglichkeit, dass und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie das und das tun und dann wären sie ja evil und deswegen, weil sie das theoretisch kunden könnten, dann denke ich, dass sie jetzt schon evil sind und dann machen sie tatsächlich das Gegenteil davon.
Da kann man ja noch an die Geschichte mit den oh Gott, jetzt habe ich den Namen vergessen. Aber mit diesen Chips in den ersten Intel-Rechnern. Diese TPM-Chips. Und da haben sie ja auch schon alle doll rumgeheult und dann hat sich herausgestellt, dass es erstens überhaupt gar nicht benutzt wird und dann sogar noch um es total irgendwie in die Argumente zu nehmen, dass in den nächsten Modellen dieser Chip gar nicht mehr drin war.
Damit auch alle anderen wissen, wovon die reden, wir reden von diesen Trusted Platform Modules, von Trusted Computing. Ist irgendwie gar nicht mehr so richtig in the news, aber auch da haben wir genau das gleiche Problem. Im Prinzip ist das ja so ein Hardware Signing. Dass die ganze Hardware well defined ist, dass dir da irgendwie nichts reingekrochen kommt. An sich eine sehr gute Idee, um die Integrität eines solchen Systems sicherzustellen und zu sagen, dieses Programm darf eben auch nur auf diesem Rechner laufen. Gerade in so Business Kontexten. Das iPhone macht ja im Prinzip auch nichts anderes. Und diese Chips waren halt in der ersten Generation tatsächlich drin, bei den Intel MacBooks.
Die sind jetzt wieder raus?
Die sind schon in der zweiten Generation rausgeflogen. Und wurden aber auch nie benutzt. Die haben sie irgendwie standardmäßig verbaut. Keine Ahnung, ob sie sich da noch eine Tür offen lassen wollten.
Ich glaube, die waren einfach im Standard. Intel Chips hat es mit dabei und das war's.
Ich muss ganz kurz nochmal auf das Thema iPhone zurückkommen.
Gibt es eigentlich schon Firefox auf dem iPhone?
Nicht dass ich wusste. Warum Apple wirklich evil ist. Aber das wird bestimmt noch kommen. Das wäre eine lustige Sache. Warum wir jetzt kein iPhone mit Firmware 2.0 hier haben, ist, weil die Aktivierungs-Server sind down. Und ihr könnt euch nicht das Bild vorstellen, wie es aussieht, wenn ein armer iPhone-Neukunde mit seinem nigelnagel iPhone 3G da sitzt und die ganze Zeit in iTunes Reload klickt, in der Hoffnung, dass der Server wieder da wäre. Das ist ein entwürdigendes Bild. Das ist ein Verstoß gegen die Menschenwürde, diesen Aktivierungs-Server nicht stabil genug zu machen, sondern die sind down, die Scheißdinger.
Sind down oder sind überlastet?
Sie sind komplett überlastet.
Sie liefern auf jeden Fall schöne vierstellige Fehlernummern.
Und man kann sich in Amerika, wären die Telefone darum, wenn man die bei AT&T kauft, mit aktiviert zu Hause. Also darüber kommt man dann doch wieder unaktiviert an den Telefon ran, indem man einfach den Server überlastet. Aber das war wirklich kein schönes Bild, das vorhin zu sehen. Ja, aber es war dramatisch.
Was sollen die Hörer denken? So, wollen wir mal in die Gerüchteküche einsteigen? Ach nee, ich wollte jetzt noch, wo du gerade so schön deinen Lieblings-Switcher benannt hast, würde ich das auch nochmal tun. Das Tool, an das ich sowieso nicht arbeiten kann. Also ich stoße sozusagen sofort gegen die Scheibe, wenn auf einem Computer nicht Launchbar installiert ist. Das ist eigentlich das erste, was ich immer tue. Das Tool kostet, letzter Stand 25 Dollar, glaube ich. Kommt aber aus Österreich, interessanterweise. Und ja, ist so ein Launcher, mit dem man halt Programme starten kann, über Tastaturabkürzungen. Ich drücke hier, ich hab mir das auf Ctrl-Space konfiguriert, dann kommt oben so ein kleines, so eine kleine Fenster, kann man gar nicht sagen, so eine Zeile unter dem Menü rausgefahren. Und dann brauch ich nur ein oder zwei oder drei, oder wie viele Tasten auch immer ich meine, Tastendrücke ich möchte.
Aber das Programm ist jetzt auch schon mehrere Jahre, oder?
Ja, das gibt es schon ewig.
Das gibt es schon wirklich lange, aber es ist einfach ein...
Das gab es noch vor Spotlight, richtig?
Das gab es schon vor Mac OS, das ist noch von Next Step übrig geblieben.
Was? Nein, Launchbar nicht.
Doch, doch, ich hab auch.
Was? Ich hab mal eine Geschichte von dem Programm gelesen, also es hat angefangen irgendwann Anfang der 90er, Mitte der 90er als Shell-Script auf einer Next-Maschine.
Oder war es dieses Quicksilver oder wie es heißt?
Nein, Launchbar, Launchbar. Also damals unter der Abkürzung LB, und dann haben sie irgendwann mal ein richtiges Programm daraus gemacht und dann sind sie auf dem Mac portiert. Also die sind schon älter als das Betriebssystem.
Verstehe. Naja, das würde so einiges erklären.
Und Quicksilver ist neben Zusammenhang, weil natürlich jetzt an den Kommentaren würde jetzt wieder kommen, Quicksilver ist ja viel besser. Das habe ich übrigens Tim auch mal gesagt und kostet nichts vor allen Dingen. Aber ich habe mich eines Besseren belehren lassen. Also Launchbar hat doch wirklich einige Features, die drin sind, die dieses Geld gut angelegt sein lassen.
Also Launchbar gab es schon für Next- und OpenStep. Das ist wirklich älter als wir.
Ja, Launchbar ist super. Ich habe es auch mit Quicksilver probiert. Quicksilver war einfach ein bisschen zu flashy. Das ist das erste. Und vor allem, mir fehlten einfach so zwei, drei Features, die ich bei Launchbar die ganze Zeit benutze, habe ich da nie hinbekommen. Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass es da nicht geht, aber alleine, dass ich es nicht von mir heraus hinbekommen habe, das hat mich schon gebremst. Auf der anderen Seite, Launchbar hat alles getan, was ich wollte. Eine Sache, die ich z.B. Also ich benutze bei Laibe nicht alles, was dieses Programm bietet. Also eine riesige Möglichkeit zuzugreifen auf die iTunes-Library, auf alle Bookmarks von allen Browsern, auf Favorites und Bookmarks von hier so CyberDuck und solchen Sachen. Du kannst die ganze Programmiererdoku schnell durchblättern. Aber was ich im Wesentlichen benutze, was für mich allein schon ausreicht, ist erstens schnell Zugriff auf das Adressbuch. Der hervorragend funktioniert, insbesondere mit diesem speziellen Feature des Subselects. Man kann einfach für bestimmte Kategorien, die man eben schnell erreichen möchte, sagen, hier möchte ich gerne ein Subselect machen. Das bedeutet, ich drücke Ctrl-Space, dann drücke ich A. A merkt er sich das erste Mal, wenn man das sozusagen auswählt, ist Adressbuch, dann drücke ich nochmal Space. Dann kriege ich ein Eingabefeld in diesen Dings, was da unten rausgedingst ist. Nee, stimmt gar nicht. Kein Eingabefeld. Dann gebe ich sozusagen neue Kürzel ein. Die werden dann aber nur innerhalb des Adressbuchs angewendet. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel deine Telefonnummer rauskriegen möchte, drücke ich Ctrl-Space-A, Space-Max.
Das klingt.
Und dann habe ich dich schon, dann kann ich irgendwie mit Cursor rechts auch noch reingehen, direkt E-Mail-Adresse, alles andere auswählen, groß anzeigen lassen, kopieren können.
Mit Quicksilver auch irgendwie gehen, aber die, die ich doch bei Launchbar, und ich habe mich wie gesagt eines Besseren belehren lassen, die ich bei Launchbar wesentlich intuitiver finde.
Quicksilver hatte vor allem einen anderen Ansatz, leicht. Also sie haben zwar letzten Endes Ähnliches getan, aber sie waren halt gleich sehr offen und wollten so ein Framework für alles Mögliche anbieten, das ganz gut funktioniert hat. Irgendwann haben sie dann gesagt, wir machen jetzt Open Source, aber im Prinzip haben sie auch gesagt, wir stellen die Entwicklung ein. Ja, sie wollten eigentlich wohl nicht mehr so richtig dran arbeiten, haben gesagt, dann machen wir es lieber Open Source, seitdem hat sich da auch nicht mehr viel getan. Da zeigt auch, dass Open Source allein halt nicht so viel bringt. Also ich kann auf jeden Fall launchbar jedem nur empfehlen, sich das mal anzuschauen. Die zweite Sache, die ich am laufenden Meter benutze, die für mich das noch sehr viel wertvoller macht, sind die Search Templates für Web. Sachen wie bei MacUpdate was suchen, in der Wikipedia was nachschlagen, in der Internet Music Achieve und so weiter. Also alles, wo man irgendwie suchen kann, mache ich über Launchbar. Wenn ich in der Wikipedia in der Deutschen was nachschlage, mache ich Control Space DE, dann weiß er, aha, deutsche Wikipedia, dann drücke ich Space und jetzt kommt das Eingabefeld und dann gebe ich einfach einen Begriff ein, zack, return und dann baut er mir die URL daraus zusammen für die Wikipedia. Ich kann halt an der Stelle auch sagen, ob er das Latent 1 oder mit UTF-8 encoden soll und so weiter, dass es einfach genau passt und dann, bumm, kriege ich ein neues Fenster in Safari oder was halt auch immer der Default-Browser gerade ist, auch ich ändere das ja am laufenden Meter und dann habe ich die Seite vor mir. Das heißt, ich muss vor allem überhaupt nicht darauf achten, was mein Kontext gerade ist. Ich muss nicht in irgendein Programm wechseln oder sonst irgendwas, sondern ich will was nachschlagen, zack, babam, bam, bam, bam, zack und so bin ich da.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich LaunchBan nur dann ich benutze, um zum Beispiel ein Programm zu starten, wenn ich gerade ein Programm frisch installiert habe und LaunchBan auch nicht die Zeit hatte, das festzustellen, dass da ein neues Programm da ist und initiieren muss.
Das geht aber mittlerweile auch wirklich rasant.
Ja, aber man schiebt es ja gerne rüber und möchte sofort starten. Das geht auch fast schon sofort. Bei mir leider nicht immer. Aber, und er kriegt es sehr sehr schnell mit, aber nicht ganz schnell genug.
Dann machst du einmal Apfel 0 und dann hat er das.
Apfel 0?
Dann scannt er alle Verzeichnisse, die er sich anschauen soll, schnell durch und dann hat er 0,0 indiziert.
Aber er kriegt doch ein FS-Event dafür eigentlich.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob sie das machen, also ob sie das nutzen. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie das machen.
Wir haben bei der Vorstellung von 10.4 von so einem Ars Technica Artikel vorgestellt, Tiger auf, also 10.4 auf einem Ars Technica Artikel vorgestellt haben, dass da so ein Video war, wo in einem Fenster war ein Terminal und im anderen Fenster war ein Finder mit zwei Programmen drin und da hat er im Terminal eingetippt, dass er die beiden Files löscht will und da hat er Return getippt und in dem Augenblick sind sofort die Files im Finder verschwunden und das ist auch mit den App-Essence und so solltest du Launch-Prengen auch machen.
Also so sollten sie es vielleicht machen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob sie es tun. Also sie können das so machen, ich weiß bloß nicht, ob sie es machen. Ich habe es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht überprüft. Es war für mich eigentlich immer schnell genug und wenn es halt in dem Moment, wo ich es jetzt gerade installiert habe und gleich was starten will, nicht da war, mach ich einfach Apple-Null und dann ist das ja auch durch. Also nach, das macht man genau einmal.
Ich benutze Spotlight und für den Rest benutze ich Google.
Spotlight wäre mir einfach zu langsam. Launchbar ist wirklich für die Leute, die auch wirklich keine Geduld haben.
Und Launchbar lernt dazu. Das macht Quicksilver behauptet es zu tun oder dachte, es würde es tun?
Genau. Und das ist nämlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich Quicksilver nicht benutzt habe. Weil dieses Lernen einfach nicht so gut funktioniert wie bei Launchbar. Launchbar merkt sich zum Beispiel auch, wenn du wirklich so drei oder vier Mal ein Kürzel, was du schon die ganze Zeit für ein anderes Programm nutzt, für ein neues Programm verwendest, dann steigt das dann in die Top 1 auf. Ich glaube, nach dem dritten Mal ist das sozusagen...
Man kann ihm schnell Tippfehler angewöhnen. Was mir gerne mal passiert, dass ich mich vertippe, während ich so einen Namen eingebe. Und da lernt Launchbar auch sehr schnell dazu. Das ist wirklich eine tolle Sache.
Gut, jetzt haben wir uns aber auch genug gelobt, das Programm, finde ich. Aber Launchbar ist auf jeden Fall eine tolle Sache.
Wie viel haben wir denn bisher? Wie viel Zeit eigentlich?
Verbraucht. Bei unserem tollen Podcast hier. 1,5 Stunden haben wir.
1,5 Stunden.
Ja, wir haben noch nicht einmal über die neuen MacBook Pros geredet.
Es gibt keine neuen MacBook Pros.
Stimmt, es gibt keine neuen MacBook Pros, sondern es gibt Bilder von der Unterseite. Und da seht ihr mal, mit wie wenig wir mittlerweile schon zufrieden sind in Sachen neuer Mac-Themen, von der Unterseite des Aluminiumgehäuses, der möglicherweise neuen MacBook Pros, falls ihr nicht gefälscht habt.
Also man hat genau nichts erkannt und nichts gesehen.
Du meinst, das ist nicht wahr?
Also, es klang plausibel, dass man die gesamte Bodenplatte annehmen kann, und da an den Rahmen ranzukommen?
Ja, man kann dann die Festplatte leicht wechseln. Erinnert ihr euch noch? Das war für mich der Hauptgrund, mir ein MacBook zu kaufen.
Wo sieht man denn, dass man die Bodenplatte schnell wechseln kann?
Weil man hat diese komplette Platte, und da ist so ein kleiner Schieberegler quasi. Und wenn man den öffnet, so ist die Vermutung, so ein Latch, dann kommt die gesamte Bodenplatte an. Und ich gehe nicht aus, dass man dann sofort an den Enden rein ist, aber ich nehme an, dass man dann...
Die ganze Bodenplatte, und ich dachte der hintere Teil, so ein hintere Streifen, so ein Fünftel oder so.
Also auf jeden Fall so was, dass man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so was wie so ein Akku hinten rausragen sieht aus dem Gerät.
Deswegen war das so gerade abgeschnitten. Ich dachte, das Bild war irgendwie so...
Akku und Platte soll er angeblich drin sein.
Aber auf jeden Fall wahrscheinlich die Versut in Ram bestimmt auch noch.
Ich fände das auf jeden Fall gut. Und wenn sie noch diese komischen Schnippelverschlussnippel dann auch noch wegmachen und ordentlichen Magnetverschluss machen wie bei MacBook, dann könnte das Gerät ja gleich wieder attraktiv werden. Aber ansonsten scheint es ja wieder genauso auszusehen.
Die Option wird es natürlich auch diese SSD-Platte geben hier, die Flash-Platte, weil das ja auf MacBook gerade billiger geworden ist.
Wollen wir nicht mal was über SSDs machen, weil da hört man ja so unterschiedliche Dinge von. Ich hab so richtig, also nicht heute, aber bei Gelegenheit mal, weil mal ist es schneller als Festplatten, mal ist es langsamer als Festplatten, mal verbraucht es mehr Strom als Festplatten, mal verbraucht es weniger.
Es kommt halt immer drauf an, was du mit was vergleichst.
Das ist nämlich die Antwort. Es kommt drauf an.
Ist das jetzt die Kurzweihand oder wollen wir dazu noch mal?
Also der Vorteil auf jeden Fall bei Flash ist, dass sein Kopf nirgends wo man hinziehen muss. Also er muss erstens sich nicht bewegen und zweitens muss er sich nicht warten, bis die Platte die entsprechende Umdrehung gemacht hat, sodass er anfangen kann, das zu lesen, was ihn interessiert. Und deswegen ist SSD halt latenzmäßig schneller, was gut ist für Random-Zugriffe, was ja große Datenangaben, die die ganze Zeit nur andauernd irgendwo was lesen müssen. Da ist SSD auf jeden Fall besser.
Aber auch da gibt es nochmal Unterschiede. Also es gibt wohl auch Hyper... Aber das müssen wir nicht heute machen. Da sollten wir uns lieber mal mit beschäftigen mit dem Thema.
Ich hab da so ein bisschen gelesen, weil ich mach ja viel mit ZFS und Sun ist da gerade dabei, dem ZFS auch irgendwie lauter Sachen mit einzubauen, die es ermöglichen, SSDs besser zu nutzen, als wenn man sie einfach so nur als Platte nimmt.
Was wahrscheinlich vor allem das Weglassen von Festplatten-spezifischer Optimierung ist, oder?
Sie meinen, dass du die Latenz runterkriegst, indem du dir so einen kleinen Festplatten kaufst, die mit 15.000 Umdrehungen laufen, aber die kosten dann auch das Fünffache von einer normalen Platte. Die sind richtig teuer, verbrauchen viel Strom usw. Und SSD hat eine bessere Latenz als diese 15.000 Umdrehungsteile und verbraucht aber nicht so viel Strom. Zumindest nicht so viel wie diese 15.000 Umdrehungsteile. Dann gab es aber von Tom's Hardware oder so einen Artikel, dass SSD angeblich so viel Strom verbraucht wie eine normale Festplatte. Die haben aber auch wiederum die ganze Zeit irgendwie auf das SSD gefeuert und drauf rumgeschrieben. Da müsste man auch erstmal gucken, den Vergleich, wie ein SSD Strom verbraucht, wenn halt gerade nicht passiert.
Ja, es gab schon einige Antworten auf diesen Tom's Hardware Artikel von anderen, die es explizit auch mit dem MacBook Air getestet haben, die teilweise zu ganz anderen Ergebnissen gekommen sind. Also, da ist das letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen.
Alles noch nicht so easy.
Über kurz oder lang verspricht es dem, meiner Mann. Also ich meine, du hast halt nicht mehr dieses, es gibt halt keine Festplatten, es gibt keine Headcrashes mehr.
Keine bewegenden Teile halt. Ich schmeiß jetzt mein iPhone nach Hause, komm immer so aufs Bett, damit ich später irgendwie da hab. Und das kannst du mit dem iPod, mit der gerade, wo die Festplatte läuft, den hätt ich nicht so mal auf mein Bett geschmissen. Und mein Bett ist schon weich.
Das ist mir bei meinem iPod Touch, äh Quatsch, iPod Nano damals auch aufgefallen, dass man mit dem, mit diesem Kaugummi-Regel, wesentlich brutaler umgehen konnte, als mit diesen Festplatten.
Ich meine, wie viel, also es gibt eigentlich keinen, den ich nicht kenne, ne, wie rum, ist egal. Jedenfalls alle Leute mit einem iPod sagen, es ist kaputt gegangen, dann fragst du, was war's? Ja, die Festplatte zickt, es ist irgendwie kaputt. Ist immer die Festplatte.
Ja, kann ich auch noch mal.
Siehst du, da, plus eins.
Ja, das ist auch the truth about hard disks. Und ich meine nicht, dass SSD nicht auch kaputt gehen kann. Das ist halt auch nur Sand.
Aber da, also weil die haben ja eine eingeschränkte Schreibrate. Also das gibt es ja wie 100.000 Mal, da darfst du irgendwie so drauf schreiben. Und dann denken immer viele nachher, nach so einem Jahr ist dein SSD irgendwie kaputt. Aber es ist gar nicht so schlimm, weil erstens sind da so real leveling Algorithmen drauf, die dafür sorgen, dass immer das, was du drauf schreibst, immer wieder an eine neue Stelle kommt. Also es rotiert die ganze Zeit im Kreis, sodass wirklich der gesamte Platz ausgenutzt wird. Und dann, wenn man dauerhaft draufschreiben würde, diese 100.000 Mal oder eigentlich sogar eine Million Mal, es ist gar nicht 100.000, weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau, dann geht es schon. Also du könntest hintereinander wegschreiben, das Ding würde zwei, drei Jahre halten und man schreibt nicht hintereinander weg auf seine Platte. Jetzt habe ich schon wieder das gleiche T-Shirt an, hättest du es nicht sagen können, hättest du es anders angezogen.
Ich mache hier gerade so ein bisschen Fotos.
Ich habe es noch geahnt beim Anziehen, da dachte ich mir, naja heute machen wir ja sicher keine Bilder. Der Max macht gerade Bilder. Der hat nicht mal gefragt. Manno.
Das ist eine Frage vor der Veröffentlichung.
Ja, jetzt muss ich mal angucken, was du jetzt wieder für kompromittierende Hintergrund-Bilder hier eingefangen hast. Vor allem, Mensch, das ist doch hier Audio. Aber wir sind sowieso nicht sicher.
SSD ist auf jeden Fall aber die Zukunft. Ich will jetzt ja nicht für Sun so viel Werbung machen, aber es gibt auch so ein paar schicke Artikel von denen. Da sollen noch interessante Hardware dieses Jahr rauskommen, wie Sun Storage Server oder so. Die halt noch Platten drin haben eine Menge, aber auch schon eine Menge SSD, was das ZFS dann benutzt, um das sogenannte Intention-Log irgendwie drauf zu schreiben, was halt schnell gehen muss. Und da ist die geringe Latenz von SSD besonders positiv zu vermerken. Ich kann ja nochmal einen Link geben von so einem ZFS-Developer, der da ein bisschen was geschrieben hat, und dann können wir es ja in unsere Linksammlung mit reinpacken.
Ich muss das hier wahrscheinlich die Sendung etwas ohne ausführliche Links erstmal posten, weil ich morgen ganz früh ins Flugzeug steige.
Oder im Kommentar nachliefern, das kriegen wir schon.
Also für diese Round-Wrek-Geschichte habe ich dir zwei Links zugeschickt, da gibt es auch einen schönen Podcast dazu. Das ist eine echt süße Geschichte.
Kann man sich mal anhören, so ein Mädchen. Zum Thema hier, man wird überall fotografiert, passt auch schön die Meldung, das ist in Berlin. Die Google Street View Cars gesichtet worden sind. Es gab schon mehrere Fotos in der Blogosphäre, wo Leuten dieses Teil über den Weg gelaufen ist.
Darf ich mal kurz einen Szenarplus für diese für diese grandiose Überleitung machen?
Großartig. Es gibt da auf jeden Fall interessante Bilder. Es ist wirklich, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, es wird ein kolossaler Aufbau. Das Ding ragt gut zwei Meter nach oben, da hab ich so den Eindruck, also oben auf dem Dach des Autos mit Stützen befestigt. Das ist halt so ein riesiger Pole, wo Zeug drauf ist.
Hast du das schon mal gesehen, diese Karre?
Ich hab sie selber nicht live gesehen. Ich hab jetzt nur die Fotos gesehen. Hast du noch keine gesehen?
Ich hab Fotos davon gesehen, die stehen ja immer am Ernst-Reuter-Platz rum, wohl nachts und am Wochenende. Ach. Und direkt neben einer TU quasi, da auf diesem Parkplatz.
Die lassen die nachts einfach draußen?
Ne, nimmt das Gerät ab oben nämlich an.
Nee, das glaub ich nicht. Das ist so fest gemacht.
Da kommt oben drauf, kommt dann irgendwie so eine Schutzhöhle.
Jetzt klauen die dem noch sofort weg.
Ja, ich wundere mich auch. Ich will so einen Teiler haben.
Also.
Ernst-Reuter-Platz.
Am Ernst-Reuter-Platz.
Ja, aber ich find's interessant, was da alles drauf ist.
Kann man zuerst bei Graves vorbeigehen und dann, da ist hier ein Aufsatz-Klauen.
Wollen wir mal kurz erzählen, was da drauf ist? Also, erstens ganz klar, also sie haben oben natürlich Kameras drauf, mit denen sie klar die Fotos machen, wie man das ja kennt, aus dem Street View.
Acht Stück, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Acht Stück im 45 Grad Abstand, die wohl dann sehr weitwinklig sind, weil sie ja auch bis nach oben gehen. Ich dachte ja immer, das wäre so Fischaugen-mäßig, aber keine Ahnung. Das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Achterblock von Kameras. Das ist ganz oben direkt da drunter.
Aber das war schon ein Rundumbild, weil Google Street View ist ja ein Rundumbild.
Ja, ist ein Rundumbild, aber es geht ja auch sehr hoch. Also, du kannst ja auch nach oben und nach unten gucken.
Das wird dann wahrscheinlich nachher zusammengesetzt.
Das nach unten ist ganz interessant, das setzen sie sozusagen aus den Luftbildern dann noch mit dazu.
Ach.
Naja, weil unten ist ja das Auto. Und das Auto sieht man aber jetzt nicht mehr. Am Anfang bei den ersten Bildern hat man das Auto gesehen, wenn man runter gedreht hat. Sie haben ja einiges verbessert. Und sie haben ja auch dieses Privacy-Feature mit eingebaut, dass sie jetzt automatisch Gesichter und Nummernschilder erkennen und ausblüren.
Und zwar auch Pferdegesichter halt.
Pferdegesichter?
Screenshots gesehen, also wenn du an der Pferdekutsche lang gewohnt bist, dass man das Pferd nicht wieder erkennt. Dann hat man auch das Pferd nicht wieder erkannt. Also es funktioniert auch mit Haustieren.
So, was ich aber noch viel interessanter fand und was etwas bestätigt hat, was ich mir schon vorher gedacht habe, ist, dass das Ding Infrarot Laserscanner hat, unterhalb der Kamera.
Hab ich auch irgendwas gehört. Genau, die können die Höhe von Gebäuden bestimmen dadurch?
Die Höhe und ich würde sagen, die können einfach die gesamte Oberfläche sozusagen abtasten. Das heißt, während sie durch die Straße fahren, kriegen sie auch wirklich das Gebäude als solches.
Damit sie 3D-Gebäude erstellen können?
Genau. Und die 3D-Gebäude, die jetzt in Google sichtbar sind, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schonmal angesprochen hatten, ich glaube nicht, ne? Sind halt, meiner Meinung nach, hart noch einer Bestätigung, aber das ist so offensichtlich durch diese Streetview Cars zusammengebaut mittlerweile. Das heißt, am Anfang haben sie teilweise einfach 3D-Daten, die öffentlich verfügbar waren, genommen. Zum Beispiel in Japan hatten sie irgendwie vor zwei Jahren, schon von heute auf morgen auf einmal alle Häuser in ganz Japan, was daran liegt, dass in Japan das alles sehr genau erfasst wird. Und dann haben sie sich wahrscheinlich die Public Database geholt und mal konvertiert.
In Berlin war es genauso. Da gab es ja mal so ein Projekt, wo die gesamte Instanz wurde.
Das haben sie aber glaube ich nicht genommen, aber sie haben auch vor kurzem alle Gebäude eingeschaltet. Aber es ist nur ohne Textur grau und ohne Dach und so weiter.
Ich dachte, das hätten sie aus Überflugdaten oder sowas ermittelt, dass sie da vielleicht die gleichen Sensoren unten dran hängen haben.
Dann hätten sie ja da keine Linie, wo jetzt das eine Gebäude aufhört und das andere Gebäude anfängt. Das ist ja wirklich so katastomäßig, wirklich jede einzelne Unit.
Ist das nicht relativ harmlos, mit Satelliten drüber zu fliegen und eine Höhenmessung zu machen?
Mit Satelliten sowieso nicht. Was machen die per Flieger? Ich kann jetzt auch nicht so einen Meter Unterschied... Guck dir mal die Daten genau an. Da sind Katasteramt-Informationen quasi mit drin, wo das eine Grundstück aufhört, wo das andere Grundstück anfängt.
Man kann ja auch Stockwerk-Informationen dafür benutzen.
An Stockwerk hilft dir da auch nicht weiter, wenn da fünf Häuser sind, die alle gleich wachsen.
Dann weißt du ja nicht, ob es ein Spitzdach ist oder ein...
Okay, wir befinden uns im Bereich der Mutmaßung. Jetzt allerdings, was ich gesehen habe, ich habe einige Gebäude gesehen bei Google Earth. Ich bin mal ein bisschen herumgeflogen in so amerikanischen Städten, wo etwas ein bisschen detaillierter ist. Dann habe ich eins gefunden, wo in diesem Gebäude komplex gerade ein anderes Gebäude gebaut wurde. Und perfekt in 3D nachgebildet, komplett mit allen Texturen, war ein Baukran. Ein Baukran, der wirklich voll 3D modelliert war. Kannst du das mal nicht mehr aussuchen? Nicht mit den einzelnen Streben, aber halt so...
Also so genau, wie man ahnt, was so ein Laserscanner ist.
Genau. Und dann, wenn ich mir denke, wenn sie da wirklich mit dem Scanner rangehen, bzw. vielleicht... Ich dachte, ich hab gar nicht erst an diesen Scanner gedacht. Ich dachte mir nur, wenn die von mehreren Orten ein Bild machen und sie wissen von jedem Bild, von wo aus das gemacht wurde. Und das wissen sie ja, weil sie ja GPS haben. Dann gibt es ja mathematische Verfahren. Da gab es auch so ein Forschungsprojekt bei Microsoft, wie du eben aus diesen Ansichtsbildern 3D-Modelle machen kannst. Bei Microsoft war das übrigens ein Projekt, wo sie Flickr-Bilder genommen haben. Ohne genaue GPS-Daten und sie haben nur sich die Bilder angeguckt, festgestellt, welche in der Nähe waren und daraus 3D zusammengebaut.
Das ist so ein schönes, großartiges Projekt.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie es heißt, aber wenn du auch noch die GPS-Daten dazu hast...
Das suchen wir noch mal raus, dafür lohnt es sich echt, um das mal auszuprobieren, die Software lohnt sich, das Windows hochzufahren.
Das ist in diesem Earth...
Nein, das gehört nirgendwo dazu. Das ist ein eigenes Projekt. Da gibt es auch bei TED, glaube ich, eine ganz große Webseite, ted.com, wo man sich so Vorträge von so einer Konferenz angucken kann. Da haben die auch mal einen Vortrag gehalten. Ich suche das noch mal raus und pack noch mal ein paar Links rein. Und da kann man mit dieser Software selber rumspielen. Also man kann nicht eigene Bilder reinstellen, aber man kann so... Die haben den St. Markusplatz in Venedig und in Prag ein paar Straßen, die sie genauso digitalisiert haben. Das macht so viel Spaß. Vor allen Dingen ist es großartig, dass man vor Notre Dame so ein Foto gemacht hat.
Ich zeige euch das mal mit dem Baumkran. Dann seht ihr das.
Kann man dazu nicht einen Link posten?
Siehst du das?
Das ist großartig. Probier mal einen Permalink daraus zu generieren. Das muss doch irgendwie gehen.
In Google Earth? Ja, eine GPS-Koordinate.
Oder wir haben einfach den Kran-Template reingeklatscht.
Das glaube ich einfach nicht. Also, so wie das hier alles aussieht, warum sollten sie das tun? Warum sollten sie einen Baukran einbauen? Ich meine, das ist nun wirklich viel zu volatile Information. Das haben sie einfach automatisch generiert und so genommen, wie es ist. Sogar oben mit diesen Drähten da oben. Naja, wie auch immer. Ich wollte jetzt nicht unterbrechen, das habe ich aber trotzdem gemacht.
Ich kriege den Namen dieser Software noch aus. Vielleicht hat noch jemand einen Kommentar. Schnell parat. Es ist echt niedlich, weil dann haben sie auch von irgendwelchen, dass dann teilweise, gerade auf dem St. Markus-Platz, dann eben auch Bilder auf Flickr sind, wie sich irgendjemand von einem Poster von dieser Kirche fotografieren lässt. Und da die Software keine GPS-Daten hat, wird dann auch teilweise dieses Poster mit eingebaut. Und beim Rauszoom hat man dann plötzlich ein Bild. Bei Notre Dame war das, bei Notre Dame Paris, wo man dann irgendjemand von einem Poster rumsteht. Und das ist halt ein Poster von Notre Dame. Und das passt halt sehr gut gerade da rein. Da kann man großartige Sachen mitmachen. Also ich, das halte ich...
Also auf jeden Fall ist es klar, man kann mit Bildern die... Nö, die haben natürlich eine Menge Geld ausgegeben und sich viele gute Forscher rangeholt. Die forschen da jetzt vor sich hin, ob da jetzt was Sinnvolles bei rauskommt.
Das ist die große Frage.
Das ist eine andere Frage. Aber ich wollte jetzt auch nicht über Microsoft reden. Ich wollte nur sagen, generell, es ist einfach klar, dass wenn man halbwegs Geokontext hat, schon ganz gute Sachen machen kann. Aber wenn man den vollen Geokontext hat, und das ist bei diesen Streetview-Cars natürlich wunderbar gegeben, weil die Dinger natürlich GPS-Antenne haben.
Bist du mal in New York mit Streetview-mäßig da so durch die Straßen gelaufen? Ist das schon der Wahnsinn?
Das ist der Wahnsinn! Da ist wirklich echt eine Menge Detail drin. Und mit diesen Laserscannern und mit diesen Kameras machen sie das so. Also meiner Meinung nach, die neuen 3D-Modelle, die mit Textur sind, sind im Prinzip ein Ergebnis dieser Karren. Obwohl es auch Ecken gibt, wo Autos nicht langfahren können, wo sie Details von Gebäuden haben, wo sie eigentlich nicht langfahren können, wo ich mich wiederum frage, ob meine Theorie so hinhauen kann. Am Ende spielt das aber alles zusammen. Was die Dinger übrigens auch noch haben sollen, angeblich...
Skyhawk Wireless Stationen.
Die machen halt auch noch WLAN-Scanning dabei. Das heißt, die fahren hier mit ihren Karren rum und scannen einfach mal alle WLAN-Netzte. Also wenn einer weiß, wo es offene WLAN-Netzte gibt, dann ist es Google. Da könnten sie auch gleich mal einen Search für aufmachen. wlangoogle.com, wo gibt es ein offenes WLAN? Aber wahrscheinlich liefern sie das alle an Skyhawk Wireless und kriegen dadurch irgendwie ihre Dienste wahrscheinlich auch noch kostenlos. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht gehört dieser Laden schon irgendwie.
Da können sie auf jeden Fall für ein bisschen was verkaufen.
Genau. Es gibt auch noch die Vermutung, dass ein Beschleunigungssensor mit dabei ist. Bei diesen Google Street-Führungen.
Ich vermute mal, um ein bisschen genauere Daten als die GPS-Daten hinzukriegen.
Um vielleicht während sie fahren noch die Belichtungszeit zu berücksichtigen.
Belichtungszeit?
Wenn sie fotografieren und wenn sie scannen, müssen sie natürlich auch wissen, wie schnell sie wirklich sind. Und das kannst du mit GPS nur so in etwa rauskriegen. Mit dem Beschleunigungs-Sensor hast du deine Geschwindigkeit exakt. Und weißt genau, wie schnell du gerade scannst. Weil die Karre ist ja im Verkehr. Die läuft ja nicht immer gleich schnell. Die muss mal schneller und mal langsamer sein.
Also ich würde mal sagen, die haben irgendwann sich hingesetzt und dieses Gerät entwickelt, was sie da auf dem Dach haben. Und dann haben sie halt alle Sensoren reingepackt, die halt irgendwie Sinn machen und nicht allzu teuer sind.
Kein Thermometer.
Vielleicht wissen sie heute noch nicht, was sie mit den Informationen anfangen. Aber vielleicht in ein paar Jahren oder wann auch immer fällt ihnen das ein. Und dann ist ja nicht schlimm, wenn man das alles mitschneidet.
Ich hab übrigens mal, ich hab es erstaunlich schnell rausgefunden, die Software heißt Photosynths. Wie wird das ausgesprochen? Foto und synths. Und habt ihr ja gerade mal einen Link zugeschickt, den du dann hoffentlich in die Kommentare mitpacken kannst, wo man eine schöne Videodemonstration sucht. Und wenn man nach Photosynths sucht, dann findet man die Software auch bei Microsoft.
Wir haben halt gar nicht bei Microsoft abgelästert.
Warum sollten wir auch?
Weil sonst immer so ein Spaß macht.
Bill Gates ist doch jetzt gegangen. Er ist doch jetzt weg. Der Feind ist weg.
Der Support von Windows 3.11 wird eingestellt, habe ich heute gelesen.
Ja, das trifft eine Industrie hart.
Das haben wir doch gelästert.
Nee, das ist so. Windows 3.11 ist immer noch sehr beliebt in der Embedded-Industrie. Das ist so irgendwie das GUI für DOS, was da weite Verbreitung gefunden hat.
Ich hab ja von meinem Lieblingsprogramm noch nicht erzählt. Ich hab auch keine, also ich hab eine ganze Menge, aber darüber will ich jetzt gar nicht erzählen. Sondern weil wir auch ein bisschen neue Sachen vorstellen wollen, kam letztens ein Programm raus, das heißt Cornerstone. Und das ist dafür da, dass man sich Subversion Repositories, also das ist eher was für Entwickler und Leute, die halt Version-Control-Systeme irgendwie benutzen. Und damit kann man sich jedenfalls Subversion irgendwie grafisch anschauen. Man kann verschiedene Revisionen miteinander vergleichen, kann alles schön mit der Maus klicken, wir haben eine ganz schicke Timeline irgendwie mit drin. Und man kann es 14 Tage lang testen, ansonsten kostet es 60 Dollar, was ich eigentlich ein bisschen viel finde. Und ich hab's eigentlich auch, wenn ich mit Xcode programmiere, ein bisschen Subversion Support, ist ja ein Xcode mit drin. Aber wenn man wirklich mit riesengroßen Repositories arbeitet und da viel hin und her vergleichen will, also mehr so Recherchearbeit, dann ist, glaube ich, Cornerstone ganz interessant. Und er casht auch eine ganze Menge. Und umso länger man ihn mit einem Repository benutzt, umso schneller wird er, weil er sich immer mehr merken kann, weil sich die History eines Repositories ja nicht verändert.
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz erklären, was Subversion ist für die Leute, die dem jetzt nicht so ganz haben folgen können. Also Subversion ist der Nachfolger von CVS und ist im Prinzip erstmal als Sourcecode-Kontrollsystem, also wenn man programmiert, zum Hinterlegen von Sourcecode in einem zentralen Ort, sodass mehrere Leute daran arbeiten können, dass man vor allem seine Änderungen definiert zurück spielen kann. Das heißt, man checkt sich das aus, kriegt eine komplette Kopie, dann macht man seine Änderungen und dann checkt man die wieder ein und gibt mit dieser Änderung auch noch so einen Hinweis, was man jetzt getan hat, sodass man eben nachträglich solche Sachen wieder rausnehmen kann zu bestimmten definierten Kunden.
Mit jeder Änderung steigt die Revision irgendwie um eins nach oben. Das heißt, irgendwann hast du Revision 100, 101, 102, wenn du merkst, dass bei 102 hast du was falsch gemacht, gehst du zur Revision 101 oder 100 oder 99 wieder zurück und jede einzelne Check-in, den kann man auch mit einem Kommentar versehen, sodass man genau weiß, warum man jetzt diese Änderung vorgenommen hat und so. Und jeder, der ein bisschen was Größeres programmiert, benutzt eigentlich heutzutage ein Version-Control-System, also Subversion zum Beispiel. Und das ist halt besonders...
Auch gut für Webseiten.
Praktisch, klar, alles was textet, man kann auch bilinaire einchecken, aber da sind natürlich die Differenzen nicht so schön vergleichbar.
Aber trotzdem, das ist grundsätzlich eigentlich für alles, was so in einem Verzeichnis abgelegt wird und wo mehrere Leute daran arbeiten oder wo man selber immer die Möglichkeit haben will, definiert zu einem bestimmten Punkt auch zurückkehren zu können, weil man mal Scheiße gebaut hat, ist eigentlich so ein Subversion-Server eine schöne Sache. Gibt es eigentlich gute Subversion-Server-Dienste, die frei sind, die man so benutzen kann? Gibt es bestimmt, aber ich jetzt keine in den Kopf, weil ich hab keine in den Kopf, weil vielleicht gibt es auch welche, wo man was bezahlt ist.
Schnell aufgesetzt, aber ja. Früher hat man Kontrollsysteme mehr benutzt, wenn man zu mehreren programmiert hat, damit man immer auch sehen konnte, was die anderen machen und deren Änderungen auschecken konnte. Heutzutage ist das schon so easy alles integriert, dass man es eigentlich auch schon benutzt, wenn man ganz alleine programmiert, weil es auch dann schon ein riesen Vorteil ist, dass man da ohne Gefahr zwischen seinen Revisionen hin und her springen kann. Ja, also vor allem kann man halt schick irgendwie zwei Revisionen anklicken.
Also ein Dip ist der Vergleich von einer Änderung vor und nachher.
Was ich ja mal nutzen wollte, ich hatte mal überlegt, so SVN oder Subversion ist in Programmiererkleisen relativ beliebt. Ich wollte das mal bei einem Verlag einführen, wo wir eigentlich den ganzen Tag über Grafiker rumsetzen, die aber natürlich im Endeffekt genau die gleichen Probleme haben, wie der normale Programmierer. Nämlich, dass da irgendjemand kommt und Dateien hochspielt und hochlädt und dass dann gigantische Mengen da sind. Dann heißen die immer Version neu, Version neu, neu, neu, Version final.
Das Problem ist nur, dass man zwischen Grafiken auch schlechten Diff machen kann. Wobei Photoshop da was anderes behauptet. Aber da fehlen einem die Tools für. Da wäre vielleicht auch so ein grafisches Subversion-Tool. Der könnte glatt sogar zwischen Bildern einen Diff machen.
Also auf jeden Fall könnte man Menge Plattenspeicher sparen, wenn man einfach ein Binär-Diff macht und nur die Unterschiede abspeichert. Und ich glaube, SVN macht das auch. Also bei CVS war es damals so. Ich glaube, das hat es nur für Textdateien gemacht. Explizit, also da konnte man nur Diff von Textdateien machen. Und mit SVN geht das auch bei Binär-Dateien.
Von Subversion übrigens gibt es auch seit, glaube ich, jetzt zwei Wochen schon wieder vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr. Gibt es jetzt auch commandline-mäßig zumindest die Version 1.5. Die hat auch größere Endungen, ist ja ein bisschen flotter und ist nur für Leute interessant, die da commandline-mäßig viel mit rumspielen. Und ich würde es jetzt selbst auf meinem Leopard jetzt hier nicht drüber installieren. Könnte man machen, aber ich will mir mein System auch nicht zerfuschen. Aber kann man sich ja mal angucken. Was noch passend ist zum Subversion-Thema ist, dass wir ja auch schon in der letzten Sendung besprochen hatten, dass der Snow Leopard ein bisschen schmaler wird, weil die sogenannten NIP-Files, also diese Next Step Interface-Bilder-Files, also wie das GUI eines Programms beschreiben, dass die ein bisschen abgespeckt abgelegt wurden. Und das liegt unter anderem auch daran, dass diese Änderungen früher binär Dateien waren, diese NIP-Files. Und inzwischen heißen sie auch XIP, also XIB, Xcode Interface-Bilder. Und das sind keine Binär-Files mehr, sondern nur noch XML, damit man eben auch sein GUI besser in einem Version-Control-System, also zum Beispiel Subversion, einchecken kann, um besser Diffs zu sehen. Das ging halt früher nicht. Du hast immer Binär gehabt, da hat er gesagt, Binär ist anders, aber hast halt nicht gesehen, was sich genau geändert hat. Und das wurde auch geändert.
Ja, die Human Readability ist auf jeden Fall so ein Ding.
Genau, hat mich früher schon mal geärgert und jetzt haben sie es endlich mal gefixt, hat ein bisschen gedauert, aber sollte jetzt besser sein.
Noch mal zu Subversion, es gibt auch noch ein, also Cornerstone war mir jetzt neu, aber es gab vor kurzem auch noch ein anderes 1.0-Release, nämlich von Versions, so heißt das, das ist auch ein Subversion-Client. Also es gibt jetzt eine ganze Menge Subversion-Clients und wie du schon erwähnt hast, sollte man noch mal sagen, also Subversion ist Teil der Bordmittel, also wenn man Mac installiert und Command-Line-Systeme, dann ist ja ganz das Subversion-Kram dabei, aber es ist natürlich nicht so einfach zu benutzen. Und diese neuen GUI-Programme richten sich natürlich vor allem an Developer, aber jeder, der wie schon gesagt in irgendeiner Form einen Haufen Dateien, der was vor allem Text ist, verwaltet und mit mehreren Leuten daran arbeitet oder selber auf eine Art und Weise daran arbeitet, wo es sehr sehr sehr wichtig ist, später zu irgendeiner definierten Version zurückkehren zu können oder vielleicht sogar mehrere Branches zu pflegen. Weißt du, hast du Version 1.3 und du hast aber auch noch Version 1.2.7 und musst auch nochmal 1.2.8 machen, sowas, verschiedene Ausgaben von irgendwelchen Help-Files oder Büchern oder Online-Dokumentationen.
Das wird alles von dem Subversion verwaltet.
Sowas kann man mit dem Subversion gut machen und diese GUI-Tools, die da jetzt gerade hochpoppen, könnten das Leuten zugänglich machen, die sonst mit der Kommandozahl nicht so glücklich sind. Es gibt auch diese Integration für den Finder schon seit längerer Zeit, es gibt dieses SVN-Plugin, was allerdings immer nicht so stabil war. Ob das nur an diesem Plugin oder am Finder liegt, das hab ich nie so richtig rausgefunden.
Das hab ich mir gar nicht angeguckt.
Eigentlich ganz nett, weil er dann mit jeder Datei, die von Subversion gepflegt wird, auch immer gleich noch so ein Overlay-Icon drauf hat, wenn es eingecheckt war zu einem grünen Haken, wenn sich was geändert hat, weil es entsprechend markiert und wenn die Datei noch nicht bekannt war, irgendwie rot.
Unter Windows hab ich das schon mal gesehen. Die Entwickler, mit denen ich zu tun hatten.
Eigentlich eine schöne Sache, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, mit dem Finder verträgt sich so recht irgendwie noch nix. Aber, ich hab ja nochmal drüber nachgedacht, könnte sein, dass SnowLab wirklich einen neuen Finder hat?
Hat oder der noch kommt?
Naja, ich meine, wenn sie alle Programme auf 64-Bit machen.
Können sie es mit dem Finder nicht machen, meinste?
Nein, Finder wäre das Carbon. Und Carbon gibt es nicht mehr an 64-Bit. Hatten wir ja schon mal drüber gesprochen.
Das ist nicht richtig.
Wie, das ist nicht richtig? Es gibt keinen Carbon 64-Bit.
Ja, doch stimmt, das war angekündigt und haben sie es gestrichen. Ich dachte jetzt nur, dass es keine weiteren Features für Carbon und 64-Bit kommen.
Wenn der Finder Carbon bleibt, dann bleibt er 32-Bit und dann wäre der Finder das einzige Ab ins Null-Appart, das nicht 64-Bit ist.
Sollte das Stiefkind von Neko Szenen etwa endlich mal eine Überarbeitung erfahren?
The All-New Finder Teil 10.
Ob es damit die Geschichte endlich mal... Das ist so eine Never-Ending-Story, oder? Der neue Finder. Ich glaube, seit 10.2 mindestens wird über den neuen Finder jedes Mal spekuliert.
Seit 10.0 wird über den neuen Finder spekuliert.
Na, da war er noch neu.
Der war nie neu.
Der war nie neu?
Der war nie neu. Das ist immer noch der alte Drecksfinder von Mac OS 9. Ja, natürlich. Deswegen ist er ja Carbon.
Dafür haben sie aber auch relativ viele Features weggelassen. Das ist ein Feature. Das einzige Feature, das ich wirklich nach wie vor tief vermisse von Mac OS 9, ist diese Möglichkeit, dass man im Finder so Fenster nehmen konnte und die unten an den Bildschirmrand kleppen konnte. Und dann hatte man diese Pop-Up-Fenster.
Genau.
Stimmt, das ist das Dock. Jetzt ist das Dock. Ist sowas ähnliches. Aber ich hätte es gern für alle Fenster gehabt. Aber egal. Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
So. Du hast aber recht.
Das muss ich noch zu 64-Bit sagen. Ich muss ja mal ein bisschen angehen. Aber ich hab hier irgendwie so ein Tool für mich. Ist jetzt auch ganz egal, was es ist. Was ich schon, glaube ich, 2003 oder so angefangen hab. Und ich hab letztens gedacht, ja, jetzt probieren wir mal ein bisschen um. Machen wir mal 64-Bit-Support. Hab ich ein bisschen rumgefummelt. Weil mein Xcode-Projekt schon ein bisschen alt war, hatte ich auch erst noch Schwierigkeiten. Hab ich mir irgendwie helfen lassen. Dann hab ich gesagt, ja, musst du halt da klicken. Hab ich gemacht. Und schwuppdiwupp. Umgestellt auf 64-Bit. Hab gesagt, compile. Dann kamen so ein paar Fehler, wo ich int benutze. Also integer. Da sagen die Apple-Jungs, da soll man ns integer hinschreiben. Weil int auf 32-Bit ist halt 32-Bit groß. Und auf 64-Bit, oh, jetzt komm ich schon wieder durcheinander. Eben nicht. Und deswegen soll man nicht mehr int, sondern ns integer benutzen. Es wird durch nen Makro, je nachdem, ob man auf 32 oder 64-Bit ist, umgewandelt. Hab ich die drei Stellen kurz geändert. Also da, wo ich so ne API benutze, wo ints Feuer vorkam. Und schwupp, fertig. Jetzt hab ich irgendwie mein Tool für vier Plattformen, nämlich PowerPC, PowerPC 64, X86 und X86 64.
Ja, das war eigentlich fast alles, was man machen muss.
Fünf Minuten gebraucht.
Das finde ich übrigens nach wie vor eines der schönsten Feature von Mac OS X Leopard. Man schiebt eine DVD rein und hat im Endeffekt vier Plattformen unten drunter auf einer DVD zu installieren. Wollen wir mal nachzählen, wie viele DVD Microsoft dafür bräuchte?
Nein, bitte nicht.
So die Sendung reicht so lange nicht.
Ich könnte ja noch nicht mal alle Betriebssysteme, die Windows heißen, aufzählen.
Also ich hatte das jetzt nicht ernsthaft vor, aber ich finde, das ist so eine wunderbar elegante Lösung. Die haben damit so unter Beweis gestellt.
Ja und auch mit allen Sprachen. Ach stimmt, das kommt noch dazu. Also wenn du irgendwie alle Windows-Versionen in allen Sprachen, ich weiß nicht, das weiß noch nicht mal Microsoft, wie viele die haben.
Also bei so einer Firma, wo ich früher war, ich glaube, die haben irgendwie, die haben das Developer-Paket bekommen, das war mal so eine riesen Kiste mit, weiß nicht wie viele hunderten CDs, das war schlimm.
Wobei das war mehr als nur Windows.
Das war alles.
Das war Office und...
Einmal das Gesamtpaket, was die so hatten.
Ja, richtig, man kriegt da immer so eine komplette Schüttung. Dann kommt da so ein Lastwagen vorbei und lädt ab.
Wobei das ist, wenn man das das erste Mal sieht, das ist schon sehr beeindruckend.
Ja, aber zweitmal nervt, weil die Tonne ist noch vom letzten Mal voll.
Okay Jungs, haben wir's?
Eigentlich haben wir's, oder? Wir können es noch ein bisschen prügeln, aber...
Und nicht aggressiv. Ich muss morgen früh...
Du musst die Sendung noch online stellen.
Ich hab meinen Pullbar verschossen. Ich muss die Sendung noch online stellen, wir haben heute nicht so viel Zeit. Außerdem haben wir schon zwei Stunden voll.
Echt?
Und von daher, denke ich mal, haben wir was getan.
Immer noch kein Pornetstuhl verdammt.
Ich hatte ja so ein bisschen gehofft, dass wir noch mehr zum Upstore und so weiter zu erzählen haben.
Wir haben schon eine ganze Menge erzählt.
Wir haben schon eine ganze Menge erzählt, aber ich denke die eigentlichen Erkenntnisse, die werden erst in den nächsten Tagen auftauchen.
Klar, wenn ich die Software habe, vorher nicht.
Genau, wie auch immer. Wir werden auf jeden Fall versuchen, in zwei Wochen wieder zusammenzukommen. Mehr oder weniger pünktlich.
Hoffentlich dann mit iPhone 2.0 Software. Also dann auf jeden Fall, oder? Bis dann kriegen wir das auf die Reihe.
Das denke ich doch schon.
Sie haben ihre iPhones alle ausgepackt und entwickeln wieder. Gott sei Dank. Das iPhone Dev Team, die sind gerade wieder das Interweb, die sind alle losgezogen und haben erstmal hier schön iPhones gekauft, oder wie die Bekloppten. Anstelle hier das Ponig-Tool für mein altes iPhone rauszubringen, was ich gefälligst mal haben will, ihr Schweine.
Die wollen auch GPS haben.
Und erzählen, ey, wir sind iPhones drauf! Macht unser iPhone endlich mal drauf. Und jetzt sind sie aber wieder.
So, letzte Frage.
Vor 18 Minuten.
Wird das neue iPhone den Erfolg haben, den ich dem alten iPhone schon vorhergesagt hatte? In Deutschland?
Was ich in meinem Freundeskreis erlebe, ist sagenhaft. Ich kenne... Also es war beim ersten iPhone ja schon stark, wenn man den Leuten in die Hand gedrückt hat, bis sie gesagt haben, wow, geiles Telefon.
Beim ersten war es noch verhalten, muss man sagen.
Genau, aber da war schon so...
Wenn es noch GPS hat... Wenn sie es hat und UMTS, dann bin ich dabei. Und jetzt kommen sie alle und sie sind wirklich dabei.
Und das ist, also ich glaube, das wird, also die anderen, es wird nicht das dominierende Telefon auf dem Markt werden, soweit gehe ich nicht, aber das wird ein unglaublicher Erfolg für Apple. Das ist jetzt wirklich, das ist, also ich hätte, sie legen noch mal eine Latte drauf, oder eine ordentliche Schippe drauf, das hätte ich, war ich mir so nicht so sicher, dass das passieren würde.
Aber wir haben es ja außer UMTS und GPS gar nicht so viel draufgelegt, also Hardware-mäßig ist ja alles dasselbe, ist auch nicht schneller geworden, die Auflösung ist die gleiche. Der Akku hat ein bisschen weniger Power, aber hält ja auch ein bisschen länger.
Software selbst, ja ja, also ich meine, vielleicht verbraucht die Elektronik einfach weniger Strom, dann brauchen sie nicht so viel Akku, ne? Da kann man jetzt erstmal nur drüber reden.
Vielleicht können wir auch unseren alten, dickeren Akku in das neue kloppen.
Ich hab meine Zweifel, dass das passt.
Aber habt ihr das gelesen, dass der neue Akku, jetzt sind wir doch hier beim iPhone, müssen wir noch ein bisschen hinziehen, dass der nicht mehr festgelötet ist, sondern so über Kontakte dran ist, also das heißt, dass man ihn einfach so rausnehmen kann.
Und das hat Schrauben.
Und dass es halt Schrauben hat und man wahrscheinlich relativ schnell rankommt, also vielleicht ist er doch schneller.
Wahrscheinlich ist das einfach auch geschuldet, dass es sich einfach als Servicen lässt vor Ort im Laden, weil sie einfach, ne? Achso, ich kann übrigens noch was Gutes zum Abschluss, noch was Gutes über mein schrottiges Nokia sagen. Das Ding lag vorgestern die ganze Nacht bei mir auf der Terrasse, weil ich das da vergessen habe am Abend. Und es regnete die ganze Nacht auf dieses Telefon ein. Morgens war es sogar noch an. Man konnte es sogar noch betreiben. Es hatte leichte Schlieren und Wasser im Display. Und die Tasten gingen irgendwie alle nicht mehr so richtig, vor allem mein Joystick nicht. Und dann habe ich es komplett auseinandergebaut. Was erstaunlich einfach ging. Also ich habe das wirklich in nur ein paar Nächsten auseinandergeschraubt bekommen. Dann habe ich das eine Weile getrocknet.
Das mit dem auseinander schrauben, das kriege ich auch mal auf, Tim.
Ich habe in der Zahnbürste die angelaufenen Kontaktstellen gereinigt und dann so zwei, drei Stunden getrocknet und siehe da. Wie neu. Wie neu. Jetzt sozusagen komplett geputzt. Ist es sauberer? Ja, sogar die Schlieren aus dem Display sind weg. Also es ist jetzt wirklich unverändert. Und so sehr ich ja diese Software hasse, darüber habe ich mich dann schon mehrfach ausgelassen. Die Hardware ist einfach spitze. Ja, das haben die jetzt wirklich raus.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, beim iPhone wäre gar kein Wasser reingekommen.
Also ich zumindest nicht in die Tasse.
Das stimmt schon, das stimmt schon. Dieser Joystick hat hier so ein richtiges... Guck mal, jetzt kann das Wasser so richtig schön reinlaufen.
Das geht beim iPhone alles gar nicht. Also wenn es erst mal runtergelaufen ist, durch die Runde kommt es auch nicht mehr hoch hier so. Also von unten kann ja gar nichts reinlaufen.
Was kann hier was in den Kopfhörer schicken?
Was für eine Sendung? Ich hab gesagt, dass Safari kein schlechter oder ein guter Browser ist. Du hast was Positives über Nokia gesagt.
Piep, piep, piep, wir haben uns alle lieb.
Oh mein Gott, das ist eigentlich... Eigentlich ist das die Love Parade Sendung, oder? Hat noch jemand ein bisschen LSD?
Haben wir's?
Hab ich schon erwähnt, dass das iPhone gar kein Garbage Collection unterstützt?
Was?
Nein, nein, das machen wir fürs nächste Mal. Wir haben's, wir haben's, wir haben's, wir haben's, wir haben's. Müllabfuhr gibt's noch im nächsten Mal.
Nächstes Mal erklären wir Garbage Collection. Dann sagen wir Tschüss.